foreign
hello
[Music]
hello
my goal in 2023 is to accomplish the
goals I set in 2022 which I should have
done in 2021 because I promised to do
them in 2020 which I plan to do in 2019
though they were set in 2016.
sounds about right drips
what up boys happy New Year happy New
Year all you too pickle Rick thank you
very much for the Super Chat just to
start it off I appreciate you man thank
you what's up chat
happy 2023 Happy New Year
wow
wow it's a new year wow
new year new spins baby
let's see if I have that working
yep we have it
I don't think we have a level
did we level after uh we beat up Gideon
I think we did
yup we need a little bit more actually
my goals are beyond your understanding
wow
wow
[Music]
New Year equal vigor
what's our vigorette
26.
not bad that means we've gotten 16 spins
for Vigor that's not that bad
it's pretty good except it's 26 that's
the bad part
that's the bad part but pickle thank you
again very much bro
hope you all had a great New Year's Eve
hope you all celebrated safely
I had a glass of wine and went to bed at
about 9 30. pretty cool right pretty
cool guy doing that
pretty cool
it's a good night
let's hope the new year changes uh
beginner's luck
yeah
Jake is going to need the lantern
should that be the first thing we do
this year is actually listen to you guys
like should I go get the lantern
no I'm not hungover at all I I had one
glass of wine literally
do you want me to go get the [ __ ]
Lantern
because here we go I'm gonna go get it
that was the wrong place but yeah when
will you spin the wheel when I have a
level to use
you goof
duh okay
I even said this here I mean I'm gonna
try and be not as rude to you this year
I told myself that and it's off to a bad
start
Lantern is based
you don't need a surprise those are your
opinions
there it is
there you go guys now you can't [ __ ]
about it
I'm gonna be bad at this I'm I'm
probably just gonna be rude all right
there you go
there's the lantern
are you are you happy now my God
you went to bed at 7am
Jesus
must have had a good night
happy New Year Zeta
bad Elden bling
[Music]
a based
based
we will always find something new to
[ __ ] about true
all right guys
what do you want to do
we have to beat
some pretty big bosses today
I don't know how this is gonna go I
really don't we may not be able to do
any of these today maybe probably we can
beat Godfrey
but we need to be god-free we need to
beat Moog we need to beat Melania we
need to beat radagon and the eldenbeast
I'm pretty sure that's it
I'm pretty sure that's it
I would like to beat Godfrey before we
go to Mogan Melania is that fair
I vote gun deer you always vote gun deer
no matter what you always pick gun deer
over your friends
just kidding and your plan was to do
this all in one day yep
that's my plan
now do those do those plans go according
to the plan
not often
uh oh yeah we have to beat place to do
sex too
[Music]
I forgot about plassy we beat malacath
that's big right
that's big
we'll take those
um
what up Joe
all right what do you guys want to do
first god-free or placidusex
placidusax was very difficult he
basically one shots us
pretty much
so if I [ __ ] up I die that's the hard
part
that's the hard part we can also go get
a plus 10 weapon
we could go do that uh in Fair Missoula
as well
Godfrey Godfrey plus Godfrey plus
Godfrey Plus
Godfrey
what let's beat Godfrey I think we can
beat him like this and then we can go
get a plus 10.
let's get warmed up for the day man
because I like to think I'm pretty good
against Godfrey but I'm actually really
bad against horlu
so
yeah we'll see
use pest thread
oh
yeah we might need to go get some like
things to help us out here for sure
hmm
so you don't need vigor
I feel like I do
I feel like I could use it
do you use gold feet
not really it's it makes a difference in
your runes but
[Music]
[Applause]
it's whatever I just like to beat boss
that's thread needs very low faith
or guys we just don't get hit
I think we can beat Godfrey like this
though I'm not sure how our damage is
gonna do
well let's see
it should be good damage
we'll beat Godfrey then we'll beat place
to do sex
Moog Melania and then radagon a long
while Alden Beast
it's the Ronin armor
dude I find horlu to be way harder than
Godfrey
yep I have tried getting good it's a
struggle it's a struggle long and hard
digital fight what's up Esther
I do want to stream a lot more this year
I do spawned by the grace of gold we
gotta change the YouTube culture to
allow live streaming because I love it
so much you're short the Eldon ring
resteth close at hand 2023 is the year
of YouTube live coming and beating
twitch
by the end of the year bro I think it's
possible
just gotta create the culture
alas I am returned beat Margaret and
Roger prior to Elder ring I never played
Souls game good [ __ ] Nathan let's go
baby
let's go to be granted audience once
more
[Music]
yeah that would be cool Solaris I
thought we were gonna fight
uh sarash
but we just don't own my name kind of
weird
twitch is kind of better Elgin Lord Give
Me A Reason how
give me reasons
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
it was nobody fought
okay okay
[Music]
our uh our damage is not the best just
lay out and you can actually see who's
live oh yeah I agree with that but I
think the streaming experience on
YouTube is literally better uh you get
higher quality streams bit rates way
[ __ ] better
um but I agree with you that like trying
to figure out who's alive is so bad I
totally agree with that
I need to turn down the music
sorry chat
you're still disserted
Godfrey is so jacked
I did get a little greedy I did
we got we got we'll get it so it's two
hits and I die [ __ ]
no this is not the drunk stream
old
we gotta beat this challenge first
we might want to go get the turtle
talisman
foreign
just to help our stamina situation
that was good
[Music]
dodged bleed
I thought he'd go phase two
I went so greed on the phase two oh
okay well that was really good until it
wasn't
oh dude yeah that's another good point
twitch ads are way [ __ ] worse than
YouTube ads they're so obnoxious at
least you can skip them here right
also if you have Prime you get one free
sub and the purple platform where here
you have to pay for it that's true I
made subbing less though
you also have to pay for Amazon Prime if
you want twitch Prime so I don't really
get that one I don't get that argument
but
fair enough
Blake for the win thanks for coming to
tarnish buddy welcome good to have you
appreciate it
it's the Ronin armor
running
okay that was good
we kind of [ __ ] up
[Music]
let's get that stamina back
oh no
that was awkward
make believe
oh yeah
nice
nice
exactly Louis I agree we'll be all
thou dids me good service
it's my favorite weapon ruins Greatsword
you guys ready for the most awkward
voice line in the game
I'll always point this out it's so bad
sorry to say
private my country's five bucks a month
gives you access Amazon Prime Prime
video so if you just already use Amazon
why not that's true
YouTube should add that to their premium
thing emergency enough
happy New Year Esther
yeah that's that kind of only affects me
Lewis but it's good for the viewer too
so you can support the Creator more
yeah the warrior Yellowstone my fight
just horror
Warrior
it's just cringe maybe I just find that
line so cringe man
[Music]
yikes bro
where are you going bro
huh
what is happening right now
it's so awkward
I don't know what the [ __ ] he was doing
there that was some really weird
movement he like went right and then
went to the left and didn't do anything
he just moved around
he's a WWE wrestler so that's why it's
cringe
okay one more attempt without the turtle
Talisman and then I'm gonna go get it
with your vids I never skip the ads you
know you can skip those and it doesn't
affect ad Revenue
all they have to do is pop pop up and
it's okay you can skip them guys I don't
mind
I prefer you skip them
what okay well let's go get it
yeah you don't have to watch a full ad
you don't have to
as long as they pop up then we're
monetized baby
uh I always have the option to make
unskippable ads which I think does pay
more but I never add that I always just
add skippable ads
all right where do I get this again
let's look over here
right here right
yeah
uh I'll just come from the church
the chitch
you have YouTube premium though I think
just like with twitch Prime if you have
YouTube premium you should be able to
become a member for free
to one one streamer
it just makes sense doesn't it
but I think twitch is trying to get rid
of twitch Prime
they just can't think of a good enough
reason to do so yet but I've heard
rumors that they're getting rid of it
or they're trying to because it does
lose them money
the Dex heirloom don't I have to do the
entire questline to get that though
no I guess I can just help her once in
it that's like the first version of it
right
uh Millicent
I could be misremembering as well okay
here we go
it'll kill their streaming service
ironically which yeah if they get rid of
it now
think it might kill twitch because it's
such a
a part of the culture
but uh yeah
maybe YouTube doesn't want to do that so
they don't have it become a part of the
culture so they don't have to deal with
it down the road right
okay what can we definitely get rid of
this
um
I don't know
radagon Source seal
archery's favor
yeah
I think this is okay
let's try it out
was I supposed to feel like she [ __ ] for
beating Demi human Queen
no
uh I'm sorry if you do
now
YouTube should offer more perks
I mean I think it's pretty good I just
like that uh the quality is better here
twitch quality is so [ __ ] bad that I
I don't even watch Twitch that much
anymore I watch YouTube's dreams
you've heard YouTube is a massive waste
of money anyway
does YouTube not make a profit
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
chat
I don't know why they'd go this long if
it didn't make a profit
I have no idea
I would imagine they do but maybe they
don't
YouTube streaming way better than twitch
they have a lot of things to make better
it's getting there though I feel it and
I streamed on Twitch for four years
was a twitch frog for a long time I
think YouTube is getting so much better
and probably has a lot to do with
twitch making a lot of mistakes the last
few years
foreign
[Music]
don't want to do that jump attack
probably
but I won't
hurry up
nice there we go
there it is
big
that was really [ __ ] good holy [ __ ]
[Music]
okay at least that didn't affect my
bubble
oh
my God
dude when do you attack
poor Lou
are there they like these just little
tiny bubbles
I think I always dislike
dive bottom through him
my PC can't handle twitch and the
quality sucks
man I did so good against Godfrey too
man
that's the best part you don't
I think you're right yo Happy New Year
Trey
did you have a good night
they banned people for dumb reasons yeah
and then they don't ban people for even
dumber reasons
you guys know that a girl had sex on
Twitch like on stream literal full-blown
raw dog sex you got a weak band
one week
[Music]
okay
foreign
foreign
big
nice
you should see trovo girls in there
always literally getting naked well
isn't that uh
I mean if it's not against their TOS I
don't know what trovo is to be honest
which loves not enforcing their TOS wow
true
all right come on let's go
big
please sir
[Music]
thank you
I'm gonna run
[Music]
nice
damn it
super dead
okay that's pretty good we can
definitely do this
I'm challenging Godfrey with morgot's
sword and horalu with
this to get horror Earth Shaker kill on
him and then that right click is so hard
to read
oh I feel you
damn
we can definitely do this though this
this is easier than malacath
we could also plus 10 our weapon
but I want to do that for Mogan Melania
we can definitely we can clearly do it
like this so we will
let's go
I think I can no hit phase one as well
if I just clutch up and get good you
know
foreign
attack good
just get the stamina back
good
stagger comes in pretty consistently
bleed there it is
greedy I didn't look at my stamina
also he looks under half I'm just saying
and he didn't switch [ __ ]
that was so good until it wasn't
go get more levels on your flask I have
26 Vigor it won't [ __ ] matter I
promise
it's not that's not the difference
yep that was greedy I thought he would
go space too though if I hit him right
there
because he was under 50 percent
at least it looked like it
yup malacath is just a [ __ ] and a half
Lewis I struggle with him every time too
I don't know what it is about him
I love this fight though Godfrey is
probably one of my favorite fights in
the game
poor Lou not as much but Godfrey is sick
okay
foreign
foreign
there's your no hit right there boys
no hit
now I understand your thumbnail yeah
there you go
okay let's go
oh that's risk
that [ __ ] kick man I hate it
it's hard to see
okay
I like it
bleed
[Music]
come
foreign
let's go
that didn't take that long
nice
that took like 20 minutes
very good
very good fight
okay
it's time for the spinny spins
it is time for thy spinny spins chat
everybody hold
thy strength befits a crown all right
there we go spin is up
see how many levels we can get
how many bosses are left we have
placidusacks Moog Melania radagon
eldenbeast
there you go
what kind of day is it gonna be
I will not be mad about strength ever
that's cool
also we have that was one two three four
five five levels
five levels that's cool all right we go
again
we need more int
potentially
[Applause]
I can't believe it
oh my God
wow
wow
it's a [ __ ] miracle
oh man
what
it's doing a row
let's do it over
what
is this madness
new year new me
oh my gosh I'm not cheating shut up I'm
not cheating Dex is good too nice
wow okay okay wow
the best spins we've had the entire the
entirety of the challenge the best spins
possible
holy [ __ ]
wow we just got so much better right
there just saying
holy freaking Toledo
oh my God okay
stop saying it's rigged
uh
got up
okay it's not rigged
it's just a miracle to you that I'm
getting lucky in any sense of the word
okay it's just a [ __ ] miracle
guys there's 120 people here and only 60
of you have liked the stream I need you
to go ahead and like the stream okay
thank you
we're gonna go ahead and point that out
as many times as we can today and see
the difference okay go and like the
stream please and thank you appreciate
it
the new year has brought us vigor
okay
let's go
and fight
placidus ax and we can go get the
upgrade as well
I like that plan
I like that plan
that is near at least we don't have to
deal with the [ __ ] Birds if we run
from this way
we'll be okay
[ __ ] Birds bro
Placid dookie I love the place to do sex
fight personally it's very cool
chat always hides it and I forget yeah I
know
it's okay I just have to remind you
Elden Lord placidusacks versus AGT Jake
not click bait gone violent
that's a good title
could be my like editor or something
let's let's go get the upgrade yeah can
I even go this way
I can okay cool
I think I've ever gone this way
there are eight stats so chances of
getting melee ones is half for what
for what for what
all right let's not get one shot by this
dragon
that'd be very not foggy
[Music]
all right
it's just a good it's just a good day
out here
we're having a great day so far oh my
wow what a what a year
let's start
this this means 2023 is gonna be a good
year chat
you guys know what my YouTube goal is
this year
I can just leave oh my god look look at
us go oh my God
you guys know what my YouTube goal is
this year or what do you think it should
be like sub count whatever you think it
should be
having one in my head but what do you
think we can get to
wonder how dude we tried plaid last time
we were getting one shot left and right
and it wasn't even [ __ ] close
152k 200k
250 my my personal goal was 500K
half a milli
half a milli
I like that I like that goal 2 video
5 000 viewers on stream
that's another good goal that we can try
for you know you guys know what we gotta
do to do that you gotta like the Stream
yeah I like the stream like a lot like
every time you come here just like
immediately
I think that's the only literal way to
go to grow a live stream on YouTube from
all my research
get more likes you get more views
when DLC comes out that's definitely
happening I mean we're gonna be [ __ ]
on it man
we're gonna be on it baby I didn't
I didn't upgrade like a dumbass
sorry
it's just a goal to strive for for the
year
all right
it's just a goal
we'll see what happens
500k is a stretch if we don't reach it
that's okay
um it is what it is
oh now
big old problem please like the stream
okay should we plus 10
Bloodhounds Fang
or Blasphemous blade
hmm
want to use spells when you have faith I
probably should
I uh I probably should
it would help with yeah
glass Fang
blasts
I think 500k is possible potentially
we'll see
does YouTube count the activity in your
chat yeah definitely
I had dude the people that are here are
always so
uh they talk in chat you know I mean
like my chat moves very quickly for the
amount of viewers that I have
which is always good
how about serpent Hunter
nah like Bloodhounds Fang is just as
good as surface hunter in my opinion at
least for this
um
how much of a difference does it make so
we'll be going from 325 to 3 45 on this
one
and we'll be going from 278 to 296 190
um
and then it scales with faith and Dex
and strength which we have a lot of
or not strength it'll switch to decks
and Faith it'll be it'll be all the same
a little bit more into faith
yeah Bloodhound I beat my first
playthrough with The Bloodhounds Fang my
first ever playthrough I beat the game
with that weapon
also Health back
I think putting it into this will be
better in the long run
and it'll be better against Melania
I'm gonna go with this
I think that's the right call
Bloodhounds Fang plus nine will be good
enough against Moog
what else do we need to go get
we should probably have like a seal to
at least have the option to use faith
uh incantations
where where is that where's the best
like where's the god seal whatever it's
called
God Slayer seal where's that
yeah Blasphemous is fire now not holy
it's in Stormville on Stormville
where in Stormville
I don't remember where
I'm gonna use it too [ __ ] it
you're not so many Maps I just haven't
[ __ ] grabbed because I know where I'm
going
Courtyard
it's just in the middle of the courtyard
like in here
what are you drinking I drink these
Celsius drinks
which is zero sugar zero calorie like
kind of energy drink it has a lot of
caffeine though
but it's got like B12 in it and vitamin
C
you know or sorry it's 10 calories not
no calories
this one is tropical Vibe and it's quite
tasty
it's near the gate
in a room to the left like over there
let me beat up everyone here
God damn
out leveled and outclassed
oh I gotcha
so it's not this yeah
I want to do a video on these paintings
like on the painter
because they're so interesting and
they're in very unique areas
I'm gonna do that soon
the healing is too good yeah but I don't
get hit
you know what I mean
I just don't get hit bro
[Music]
okay I got hit there
some of these doofuses just don't move
ow
wait I get health back just by hitting
them
I don't even have to use the the weapon
art
it's in here right
and up
oh man this weapon is really good huh
this weapon's badass
I thought I had to use the weapon art
cat that's arrows
out the door into your left
gotcha
over here over Yonder
no it's not my Talisman that does that
or is it
wait I gotta go through here
only heal on kill got it
is it through here
I'm not gonna lie to you chat I don't
think I've ever been in here ever you
guys have opened my eyes
to the fact that I'm just bad at
exploring
why is this here
by the way maybe they stole it
oh and they gave you the prayer book
let's go
why is that there
lore wise
okay
um
are we even like close to getting a Moog
we need the secret Medallion or both
anyway
so
or is vari's Quest still an option here
no I don't want to go online so yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
we go here
God skin and grafting
yeah that's definitely a comparison that
can be made for sure
that is definitely a comparison that can
be made
we can definitely do a spinny spin here
too
yep
there's an NPC for vari's Quest now
oh it can be done offline are you serial
oh what would be faster
because we'd have to kill uh
the dude in Castle soul
what do you think would be faster wait
that's all my stats you don't need to
see that chat you don't need to see that
okay
Bang
we definitely have one level
gotta go to snow field for Millennia
anyway so no point
yeah I think we should just do that
one level one spinning spin
make finding new things after 700 hours
a lot of those hours was me doing the
same stuff you know what I mean more
strength let's go bro okay
it's a good day out here
it's just a good year
all right
well positivity
positive vibes okay
um
yeah let's just go get the secret
medallions I think that's fine
personally
all right where's genocide cave why am I
lost right now
who became a member Jeff
became a great room thank you Jeff I
appreciate that W's in the chat for Jeff
welcome good to have you
thank you very much sir
uh
okay it's this way
oh wait
I'm so distracted
let's see what kind of spells we got
see dude a lot of these we can't use but
some of them we can
a lot of them I haven't unlocked yet
where where do I turn in my uh
I know where
am I all over the place right now or
what bro oh my God what can I go talk to
selin no the Pope
the turtle dog of course
how could I forget
we need to go to Melania anyway boxer so
we're gonna do that
of course hey another painting
how could I forget guys okay am I closer
nope here we go
I can't wait for new content for this
game to come out I am so excited
mind a little recap we beat Godfrey
in about 20 minutes that was big we just
upgraded our Blasphemous blade to Plus
10. we got two attributes in Vigor Miro
it's been a good day
oh God where do I get the flask thing to
help with moog's knee heel
where where is that located
where I can create a bubble and it won't
hurt me
because we're just gonna need that
Altis
eleanora
you are tarnished aren't you I have to
listen to him talk I'm sorry to the
church I love this this [ __ ] dog man
Steward of this sacred chamber my
apologies it's one of the churches
do you know the origin of this place
how it came to be known as the church
okay vows
no well that is a shame
but who can blame you the shattering has
caused us
all of us to lose sight of something
very dear it is here at the church of
when he gets wind blades from houses of
the earth tree and the moon it's the
church in the plateau by the matrimonial
bond between red-haired radican
and ranala of the full moon
and so our church holds in view the
monuments of both houses okay that's
enough for now
sorry guys you are free I would sir if
you find unless in which case Okay uh
uh give prayer book oh we have a lot of
those
let's do this one what have we very well
heresy whole thing oh what very well
heresy is all thing
all thing
uh okay study sorcery
nope study incantations
wait we have black we can use black
flame oh [ __ ] okay we might have to come
back here when we have more runes
okay we'll have to come back that'll be
big for us though
let me go ahead and slap this on oh I
can't use it chat I need 27 faith
oh look all right well we're good for
now if we ever get to it it is an option
we'll take it
heresy is all things
uh what a good boy all right
yeah where's the it is there one that
requires less faith
I have the faith heirloom
I have it actually
are there one of these that I just could
not use like maybe well radagon Source
seal is kind of important isn't it
oh that's my intelligence not faith I'm
an idiot
right
okay we're asking too many questions now
let's
go get the Moog thing
which you guys said is in Altis at one
of the churches
right
like Altus this way because I don't have
my map up
the one you get from Beast clergyman
yeah we could go do that we could
be seal
can you play some rocket League comp
hello are you okay
hell no
twin blades at one of the windmills I
don't remember where that is I'm sorry
it's in between so like in here yeah
I'll go here then
yeah I think we should go get the
beastial one after we do this let's do
that that's our plan
thank you
not using sword night in flame we've
we've got our weapons that are quite
good
like we're good on weapons
you can see the church on the map
why do I not remember where the church
is
is this the church
right there
probably
talk about an area I have not explored
that much is down there
I find that area to be one of the
scariest areas in the game
are you aware of an NBC named Peta yeah
he's in uh the carrion Manor
right
Aryan
Mike said no wrong one
is this the wrong one
we'll live from this height
no prob
fish
it's the right one and a sacred tear big
mic language no equals yes got it
that's big info
did you just
chat
scared wait why did I heal I can just
heal
[ __ ] you
come back
that didn't hit ow
you're crazy
ow
there we go my God
there we go purifying Crystal tier
and her pole blade that's big
okay so we have that for Moog that's
good we want that
can you show your map we're at her
second Church of Medica
[Music]
right there
what else did we want to do I already
forgot
happy New Year Mr Burr
I already forgot we want uh
a different seal right
I don't know
okay we want a different seal Beast yep
got it I remember we want to go up here
which we can go to from here okay cool
seal from gerank
got it
I wouldn't mind checking out Mario's
quest where you don't have to do it
online I always thought you did well I
guess that wouldn't make sense
can't like not everyone has access to
online
oh Faith heirloom do we still want that
we're doing a lot of setup right now
we got we have to prepare for Mogan
Melania we have to or we'll never beat
him
hi Finn Happy New Year
it's all good how are you
let you get the lightning strike I think
that'd be pretty cool
why have two death roots
is your sling Carmike seal Beast eye
that's good
we'll take it can I use it it's the
other question I can
that's good
that's good do we want to upgrade seals
I don't really use that much incantation
so
like do we want to upgrade that
as much as we can
let's see what we can use yes okay
this is for our sorcery build we didn't
have to upgrade our staff or whatever so
I was curious
uh
right we have to go buy them
that's right
is this is beastial sling good we can
also use frenzy stuff
we have the flame of frenzy and then the
grab is that gonna help us at all
Maybe
at least we have options that's good
let's go see how much we can upgrade
that
or do we want to get enough enough Faith
to use the other one
let's go see what our options are where
where is the faith heirloom chat
I remember where a hat is
that we could wear I don't really wear a
hat it's like a mask that gives you more
faith I'm pretty sure
like
not here
remember
these scales with strength so we
probably want to use that one right
lorenia bottom right corner of the map
like way the heck down here huh
purified ruins
last scar
that's like
up here right
or even here
I think they're like right there
actually
well now someone's same left side of the
lake
I love trying to get directions from
chat
it's so [ __ ] hard
all right well here we are
um does this have like a secret area
maybe not this one
it's so dark let me light that up for
you
it's a weird time of day out here
oh up here
yeah I got the lantern right at the
beginning of the stream so you all could
stop bitching and moaning about it
stop it doggy
wrong one
right here
sir I'm gonna need you to stop thank you
this is where the faith Talisman is
you're gonna miss that bitching
[Music]
right that's where a grape is too which
one of these do we want to get rid of
is it time to be done with radagon
Source seal
probably not right
I don't feel like Dragon Crest really
does that much but maybe it does
see how much it would give us
it'd give us 28 faith
great Shield or Source seal yeah
I think we should probably
get this off
how much does radagons change us our
Vigor goes down by five
endurance up by five strength up by five
decks up by five that's so much better
yeah we got to get rid of that I think
that's our our best play for now
then we got that cool
okay
okay
now
yeah my Vigor is trash without Source
seal however we do take more damage
right that's like the the trade-off
Source seal makes you take more damage
so Vigor actually doesn't do anything
yeah but it affects our strength and
decks and you know there's other stuff
that comes with it
you have Platinum trophies
um I do for Elden ring
um I don't think I've ever I'm not big
on Platinum in games
clearly that I haven't like done
everything
but Elder ring I did
yeah okay what what's the other thing we
wanted to do
we could go get some runes and buy
uh incantations
which we have 9 800. we really don't
have enough at Turtle Boy
how expensive is that [ __ ]
we got an e heel
we did that
for the yeah
foreign
yeah I'm not a very you know do you need
we need the sword seal in my opinion
study sorcery man this shit's expensive
as [ __ ]
ancient dragons lightning strike
we can we can't afford it it's 10K which
we could go get real quick
we can get this black Flame
what do we want to use
um
like
can I use like B seal sling
let me throw that on real quick
I know you can't see I'm sorry I try to
hover over it
we can
I feel like this will be quite good for
us
it's only 10 Faith though
we could get more beastial [ __ ]
lightning strike destroys Moog
okay we'll focus on that let's go get
10K
where can we get some quick Rooney boys
many bosses are just like the last thing
on my mind
Moog is resistant to fire then we'll use
Bloodhound Spang
probably and then we can use lightning
strike with that as well
opaloons I do not have any besides that
one I just picked up
Oh you mean the balloons with the
hovering dudes
yeah yeah yeah
there's an ER tree Avatar in here
that we could kill right quick
that's we could uh
lightning strike melts plassy really
even though that's what he uses
actually that works for like all the
bosses so I I see that
and then we want to upgrade it our uh
our claw Mark seal
that's right
that's right
okay don't jump on me please
oh wait we could knock this down
let's do that
because I have all the other remembrance
like the Lesser remembrances
oh wow okay
Lassie has 40 lightning absorption
so then it's not good
yeah Lord of blood equals weak to blood
isn't that weird
you'd think it wouldn't be like that but
it is
40's low okay I don't know
I don't know this [ __ ]
which one
Regal ancestor Natural Born Lich dragon
fire giant black blade or Hora Lou
they're considered lesser I guess so
they're not real demigods that's cool
um what gives us the most runes does it
tell us
does it even matter
I mean we we're using it for runes
no great Rune equals lesser right
malacath
you lied to me earlier
Godfrey
[ __ ] it
30k
we'll take it
now
we go to dog
dog Pope
you guys see the pope died or the I
think it was a previous Pope
I'm not religious so I don't know but I
think it was an older one
foreign
ow
e chill man
foreign
bro
meat Peddler is bear bearing though
I hate this dude I think everyone hates
that guy
New Year's roast dinner that sounds good
I had one glass of wine and went to bed
that was my New Year's night I thought
it was night it was it was fun I had a
good time is this the one we want
ancient dragon's lightning strike or do
we want Lightning Spear because we need
32 [ __ ] faith for that which is four
more levels
like will this one be okay
lightning strike
no spear got it
10K by the way all right now let's go
upgrade our claw mark
this is more setup than I even like
doing I do like banging my head against
a wall
with the [ __ ] I got until I beat it but
maybe we don't do that
today
so you guys are cool with me upgrading
claw Mark seal right like this is what
we want to do probably
more Lightnings more good
through
all right wow
okay uh we need two more smithing ones
dude I hate upgrading with regular
smithing Stones it's so annoying how
many you need
if you don't like go and actively find
them
never gonna get them
okay
Bell bearing
purchase
okay two of those
yeah it is such a pain in the ass
but at least we have the thingy for it
yeah dung eater's being a [ __ ] in there
five twos
it's 12 per level that's right thank you
you just hoard them it's not a bad idea
isn't he always no most of the time that
door's closed
how many did I say five
I also do that in a very annoying way
where I don't go to I don't scroll to
the five I press it five times
I like the sound
I also don't have this one is this gonna
be okay
like a plus plus eight
for now
I guess we can go find out
let's do you
and then we have to throw [ __ ] on
it's pretty low but that's kind of how
it is that's what we're at
lightning strike
I'm gonna put on flame of frenzy because
I'm curious
and then be steel sling
get that to plus 16 minimum
let's say for what boss we're gonna go
fight Moog
that's our next uh our next boy
Mogi boy
black flame is good
okay
we'll do that over this one
okay
foreign
you know it's it's an option guys it's
an option we're gonna go see how it goes
let's go
and get all the stuff we need
um
thank you for the super sticker that's a
cute little
it looks like a samurai dog hugging a
trophy that's very cute
dovey's in the chat for Zeta I really
appreciate that thank you
thank you thank you and happy New Year
to you
happy New Year potato
everyone go check it out
brazeta
I don't know that might be cringe
[ __ ] you
all right let's go into genocide
area
I think you're right Kirby
we can always leave the fight if it's
not going well and go upgrade
together
it's really dark
good thing I have a lantern now
of our the cards
was that one
beanie bosses we beat Godfrey yep
we beat him in 30 minutes it was kind of
epic
and now we've just been doing a lot of
setup because it's required we're just
gonna have to
he said genocide he should be demoted or
criticized
yeah
probably uh according to Reddit yeah
favorite weapon in Elden ring
dude I need to make commands don't I
a lot of people ask the same questions
where we can go like it's ruins great
sword
that's my favorite
personally
personally that's my favorite
ow
l oh stop spamming
you're so annoying okay there we go
yay
please no deal me
biggest boss let down for you
no secrets lie with me not a one oh
please leave me be
the biggest boss let down oh hi we're
finished like what do I think is the
worst boss or one that I thought would
be better and wasn't if you should meet
the young then please
I have no idea Esther we're gonna try
our best
deal oh wait you you did it okay well we
don't need to see him die now we go up
top
and we gotta beat this butthole
most underrated boss underrated
I think people give godric a lot of [ __ ]
because he's pretty easy
but I think godric is one of the best
fights in the game
personally
we'll have to get that some dude
I I love the godric fight so much it is
[ __ ] awesome
that one was not a letdown I thought it
would be a bit harder but for me that's
not a letdown
godskin soldier of Knox Stella I do like
those fights they look really cool like
the design on that boss is [ __ ]
amazing
no my Beast eye Quivers
well I'm [ __ ] dead
why is this hard to get through now
torrent straight up died
oh my God
I am not fighting this dumbass bird no
nope nope nope nope nope
let's go get another uh remembrance
chat what's your favorite fight in Elden
ring your favorite boss overall
what is the best weapon whatever you're
whatever you like using
godskins can lick my balls I think we
would like the godskins if we didn't
fight them so many times
I think the godskin duo would be better
if it was just them
do I knock anything off here I
have more Millennials than I thought I'd
see
a lot more Millennials than I thought
I'd see
foreign
there we go
I don't know a single person on this
planet that thinks eldenbeast is the
best fight in the game
no shot
fire Giants your fave that's one of my
least favorite
real
am I weird for saying radagon
is one of my favorite fights
I think radagon kicks ass
with the opening music
uh radagon is such a [ __ ] good fight
and I think it's underrated because
people relate it to
the Eldon beasts which they rightfully
do because it's a part of the same fight
do I get reichardt here again because he
gives the most runes I think I do
you guys said that before so I'm just
gonna do it again
ranala is no one's favorite I like
Ronaldo
I think she's more of a gimmick fight
but yeah
grafted fight could have been more
interesting you mean godric that's one
of my favorite fights so
I think godric was really well done for
an early boss fight
okay we got I think a spinny spin we got
one spinny spin let's go boys
let's go okay
come on
give me that good good intelligence
not the best spin but it is a spin
nonetheless
it is a spin nonetheless
all right let's go what level are we
109.
wow it doesn't feel like it I'll tell
you that
I developed Stockholm syndrome syndrome
with milady
oh boy
oh boy
yo honestly I hate running through here
I hate it
we're gonna we're gonna live though
we'll be okay
oh [ __ ]
not where I wanted to go
reichardt is [ __ ] awesome
as well
okay well that was a waste now
just watched the first part and now
you're live look at me go
ledge
that was my [ __ ] fault
whatever man
[ __ ] this guy
excuse me [ __ ] these guys
oh really
cinematically with unique abilities
I think godric's one of the most
cinematic fights in the game
personally
ow
I think he's awesome I think godric
might be cons like might be the most
perfect one of the most perfect fights
in the game
you guys told me of a shortcut through
here and I forgot it and now I'm already
ahead so it doesn't matter
now just just give me this
and we'll be fine you did not do that
you did not you did not do that where he
[ __ ]
he teleports in the room so I can't hit
the grace man
[ __ ]
he teleported in
I just wanted to hit it so I like it'd
be fine if he killed me and I wouldn't
care oh my God
that's so annoying
you can go straight through the main
gate on the wood stairs
is that true
nothing personal it felt personal
you ran too slow
okay
[ __ ] you
just throws a little ass ball
MAV Albert's tongue water count as a
boss
man if it does to you
I would say a boss counts if there's a
boss meter at the bottom of the screen
there ain't no way right
like there ain't no [ __ ] shot okay
we're good
just kill just kill me so I don't have
to deal with these guys
you don't have to go through this way I
always thought you did
maybe I'm just scared of the the Lions
or whatever
foreign
oh it's an Invader in the round table
I mean I guess
I don't know
whatever your heart desires chat
whatever boss you like
it's good good on you I don't know
if I use Blasphemous blade for this
fight
probably right
let's get a little distance
yeah
yeah
oh
that's not good
yeah he [ __ ] melted
thank you
too close
oh
big
[Music]
no
[Music]
this fight cinematically is [ __ ]
awesome
foreign
that fight's really cool we kind of
annihilated him though
we kind of annihilated him
like that was supposed to be hard and it
wasn't
we gotta spin let's go
let's [ __ ] go
spend time
did I put it on screen okay I did
oh my God it's a day
it's a day baby today is a day
wow
I just can't [ __ ] believe it I can't
believe it I I can't that's it that's
amazing okay
let's go boys
big day today
three Vigor levels in one day
we can't even level that much
from now like we can't
let's go
uh excuse me
all right we got the secret medallions
for the holiday tree
I had a stroke ignore that uh let's go
let's [ __ ] go we gotta go
let's go baby
um
where the [ __ ]
oh that's up here I'm dumb there we go
it's Haley tree right
there's so many characters in the game
that say Hey Lake tree and then I swear
back in the day I'd watch a bunch of
eldering videos and never go holly tree
and then I said Haley Tree in a video
and I got corrected by like hundreds of
people bro no cap
time to get second somber ancient for
the Fang
is that in here
Vari Quest we're going concentrated snow
fields because we have to go to Melania
anyway
I think I think you're right Esther
yeah it's hey League tree
a league tree
it's a nice glass Cannon build I mean
yeah
somewhat
on the river
from NPS and NPC invasion
I don't know where that is in there
oh wait yeah I do it's Anastasia right
yeah yeah
you kill her you get a somber that's
right
ancient somber
which feels like an odd place to get one
but it's where we get one
the uh
theodorix I don't know who that is or
I'm not remembering
fake is the build you don't want to take
home to your mama
your mama would be like what the [ __ ]
are you
hate League tree that's a good one
radagon
chat would you bring me home to your
mama
you think I'm good enough
the B-side Quavers
foreign
yes
what up killer
no comment bruh come on
all you have to tell your mom just tell
your mama that I'm an online male
entertainer and I think she'll
understand
what do you do for a living Jake I'm an
online male entertainer
that could mean so many things
and she'll get so confused and it'll be
funny
you'll think you're a porn star
Maybe
it's possibility of that
nothing wrong with that in my opinion
I mean when I say I'm an online male
entertainer is that wrong
no
I'd say that's a correct statement of
what I do and who I am
I get lost here every [ __ ] time man
and I'm not fighting that guy I just
won't do it
can I drop down there
only fans coming up what did I say for
the only fans guys
what was the goal
5 000 members and I will legitimately
start one
I will do it
[ __ ] I want to look at the map I'm lost
so better start getting some members in
here bro
no I thought it was 500 you're [ __ ]
high I did not say 500.
ever
5K
only feet
where is Logan with the memberships
right
okay I found my way stop
whoa
oh man
wait what did I kill
what am I killing right now to get
health back what
huh
what the [ __ ]
oh here we go
here we go guys
so does Ronnie cosplay include feet I
was literally going to go get like
I'm gonna have four arms a dress I'll
paint myself blue we'll do makeup like
her her face as close as we can like
I'll go hard on it bro but that's at I
thought we said a thousand for that
and then only fans is 5000 which will
never reach
that's the point that's why it's 5K
where are you Anastasia all right here
we go
I mean okay she just [ __ ]
foreign
she buffed through that huh I thought
she'd stagger I really did I thought
she'd stagger what the [ __ ] dude and now
I gotta go through the whole damn area
again [ __ ]
man
I
just got annihilated
it didn't feel good either sometimes it
feels good and that one that time it
didn't
now
I hit my toe
nicer
nice suit
have you cosplayed before I dress up as
Princess Peach on Twitch
or
I think it was a thousand Subs
that was fun
I was speed running Mario 64.
yeah Anastasia is literally an insane
cannibal yeah
who's not even like she dresses up to
trick us
like a maiden
well that staggers you huh
I think you should try and not get hit
Byer
oh my God how are we gonna get through
the town
oh my God
oh [ __ ]
yeah there is a grace to the right
you're you're not wrong
let's go over there
he knocks you off the horse though
I don't want to do frenzy grab
she does not hear this time
yeah it's over here
wait I'm lost
I don't remember where this brace is
I might as well just go up to the town
at this point
yeah whatever [ __ ] it
cosplay is a wretch so just be naked
that's what you're saying
whatever I'm right here I'm just gonna
grab this
whatever mate
do a town skip how do you do the town
skip
wait is that what you guys showed me the
other day no
no
why am I fighting you that's just dumb
is she just not here this time
foreign
why is that not hitting what the [ __ ]
Eco sling sucks dick
thank you
excuse me sir
wow
why am I so bad against you right now
foreign
stop it
she's the best pvpr in the game
holy [ __ ]
there's something in my eye
so it's just bad against humanoids
got it
got it I walked into that one
okay
crew
use pole blade yeah let me use my
non-upgraded pull blade that's gotta be
better right
gotta be
because you said it
[ __ ] God damn I would have died again
let me move
oh my God
stop hitting me [ __ ]
oh my God
oh my God Kirby tell me what to do one
more time and I'm gonna [ __ ] ban you
for the day I will do it shut up
use grab
there's rivers of blood
use this use that shut up no I'm gonna
kill her
if I stop getting hit I won't die
easy as that
need more bigger
oh God
really
this is not going well like this is just
not going well at all
I'm sorry I killed one of the packs man
oh now
oh my God
foreign
ly
there we go
there we go
look they're back to playing after I
killed their family
we kill one more
see that one just went well out of
nowhere
my first attempt I literally was using
the exact same attack bloodhound's
finesse and I just [ __ ] die
immediately
so it's just like
just don't get hit it's a lot easier
isn't it
like crazy
okay here we go
not enough for a level which is not good
oh boy
the best blood weapon
um
I don't know probably rivers of blood
still
foreign
all right
this one through chat
let's go over here to start
it's just
you know
just don't get hit and we'll be okay
right
question
[Music]
it's that simple
um it's in the mountaintops of the
Giants in the church Irby
and try and not get grabbed chat it's uh
good advice thank you
how many likes are we at though I don't
care about view count I care about how
many likes we have what are we at
kitties it's starting
[Music]
like calm down lady
147 let's get that up to 150 at least
like the stream now
right now
ow
the fact that they track is so dumb okay
we might get grabbed here in a second
go go go
go
go
[ __ ]
stop it
okay here we go
stop
I'm dead
excellent
what do you say to peeps that don't like
the Stream
I don't like you
that's the answer
all right guys I got this watch
we were Bound to Die
bound
we don't need a weapon right now
we need a shield
this will be fine
I got this guys
uh ignore that though
ignore it okay here we go
ignore that too okay hold on
foreign we're gonna be fine
it's fine
we're fine
do you think Gideon could have become
Elden Lord
yeah probably
until we beat his ass
like a little [ __ ] he is
while he used us the entire game
foreign
because of that one Pole right there
this guy I think this three guys it's
gonna be fine
okay
why can't I get up here
you guys just see that [ __ ] movement
look at my movement
too good at the game
I'm just way too good at the video game
bro
please don't shoot me in the back
there we go
Pro dodges
foreign
steel broke
I took an arrow to the knee
I used to be an adventure like you and
then I took an arrow to the knee
now
I'm ass hey I can use this now
[ __ ]
wait what was better
all right boys
now let me go it like let me just go do
this let me go hit the uh
you know what
the grace
yeah you could say I was gaming there
I was gaming
Rue
a man cannot kill a god
you know what I think
chat
I think Gideon's right
when he says a man can't kill a god
that you know what that tells me
that we are not a man
we are a god ourselves
imagine that theory going around
oh boy people get so mad
we are tarnished yeah that's what they
tell us isn't it isn't that interesting
you're a tarnished I can see it
the game tells us a lot of stuff guys
why do you believe everything you hear
all right let's go to Moog
by you
Sir Charles
you're not tarnished you're maidenless
[Music]
half of the armor lore is propaganda
okay
we need to upgrade this as well oh
[ __ ] ass
no you can't fight me too you can't it's
not allowed
go away
we're running
currently running away
this Invader is a pain in the ass as
well it is true it's very true
okay
why puppy
foreign
how do you struggle with the sanguine
mobile maybe because there's a [ __ ]
bear there too bro
I could be a part of it
I hope the DLC is just Rune bears
I don't think you believe that
where is this guy is he just not showing
up no
what
or am I like way too far over here I
might be
oh
there it is
together
from the top rope a bear
what's kinda like that thank you potato
from the top rope a bear
where did that bear come from
oh it's right there okay
all right you [ __ ] hoe let's go
wait the bear is [ __ ] awake
oh God
I hate this
I hate it
foreign
get on my game
and I killed a bug it's literally harder
than killing that guy
all right
let's go boys
and girls
you know I found out I have a very solid
amount of girl viewers
I couldn't believe that
like I thought it was two percent and I
looked at it the other day and it's like
eight percent
like what
crazy where am I going
is it over this way
hey can I ping you at Discord I mean you
can
um
you know yeah
is it over here
I found it
a female gobbles
it's not what I'm saying I was just
surprised because it was two percent and
now it's eight percent
well good thing I bought that Lantern
women aren't real yes they are
they're great
women in gaming
it's good to see because there used to
be such a [ __ ] dumbass
stigma against women in gaming and I'm
happy that they're a part of it now as
they should be
yeah I bought the Lantern and my luck
changed like maybe I should just listen
to you guys
Farm spot cheese Yep this is the farm
spot
we're not going to do that because I'm
not a you know
a little hoe like some of yo
I think we were gonna have a spin as
well
[Laughter]
women are temporary PC is eternal
okay
thanks for all the lore videos Elden
ring is by far the goat for me Fame
same man
we got a spinny spin no we don't
okay dry lightning all right I'll Farm a
little bit in here watch this
I just wanted enough for a spin
I'm dead
okay I killed one
all right we got a spinny spin let's go
baby okay
uh yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
okay
is it on screen no excellent now it is
let's go
one spinny spin
all right it's a strength build guys
it's a strength build let's go baby
that's big our luck actually has turned
it's incredible
still not a build I would uh do myself
personally
but we really are out here right now
aren't we
also remind me before we fight Moog to
go upgrade our Bloodhounds Fang
oh God
and I don't know about you guys I run
through this area as fast as possible
every time
[Music]
[Music]
they do awesome cartwheels they really
do
cartwheels do be pretty cool
all right
they're big ass runes by the trees oh
true actually true
okay
let's go back now
give it a little upgrade yeah we killed
Royal ancestor Spirit we sure did
murdered that donkey
or mousse or whatever
excellent
fully upgraded Bloodhounds Fang
and blasphemous blade you guys said
Blasphemous blade is good against Mo not
against Moog right because he's
resistant against
fire
so we want Bloodhound for this guy
if we need to upgrade the claw mark
we'll do so we're gonna see how we are
as is
um since when does this guy take up the
entire path
maybe I'm an idiot
radagon in Melania is zero fire resist I
mean that's gonna be big for our in-game
then
that's big for end game
don't need to go over there
another big Rune we might be able to
spinny spin again
with the two runes we've gotten
depends on what incantations you're
using Irby
we wanted to fight placidusacks right
wait what do you guys want to do first
Moog or placidusex
probably go do plasty boy that might
take us a while
motions are already there I mean we can
be at plasti real quick
one spinny spin here we go
One Singular spinny spin
we can always use more endurance I've
said that from the start big
[Applause]
huge
big huge
very big
okay
uh you guys were pretty split I say we
do a poll
class
I'm just saying plassy
Lassie
or
mug
all right put your votes in I'll just do
whatever you guys want did you just
level mind
I don't think so I think I did endurance
[Music]
did I level mine
by accident
did I actually why would I do that what
I leveled mind no [ __ ] way
you're right
we're gonna fix this
we're fixing this
hold
everybody hold
picture taken
all right
also keep voting keep voting guys
I made a mistake I'm sorry
Happy New York golf channel in 2023 also
do we know who Elle was a church named
after them sorry if you've covered that
before I don't think we know who Ella is
no Golf Channel in 2023
I mean
it's really cold here now I I'm never
gonna say no to that but maybe we'll see
thank you for the five dollars I really
do appreciate that thank you
to become beat okay larval's here
okay guys okay here we go
so I guess it tells us what we had
24 vigor
God I wish I can go higher than that 25
mind
23 endurance
yeah and then everything else is the
same that should be how this goes
right
good
hey I don't want to [ __ ] you guys over
at all all right so we went down one in
mind and up one in endurance
that's gotta be it okay
now I can ball up excellent why do we
get that for her anyway or after
respecting
all right y'all voted for Moog so we're
gonna go fight mogey boy
and see how that [ __ ] goes
take away one Vigor for that got up
absolutely not
you could have just given yourself
endurance if you got mine in the future
no
what no we we [ __ ] up the level we
went and fixed it that's what that's all
we're gonna do of course
never thought we'd rebirth I mean I
[ __ ] up so that's why
all right guys what are our chances of
winning this fight oh physic
thank you
[ __ ] ass
[ __ ] ass
oh my God I went to the wrong one
whatever okay
last
glass
what do we want on as well
I feel like for Moog we want endurance
maybe along with this
we can get a get a hit in as well
I believe this counts
we're gonna go with this
this will be this will be we'll see how
it goes
but his dynasty is called mowgwin if
mikola if it's Michela in the thing
it sounds like God win
right
like a mix of Godwin and Moog
that's what I've always thought
we don't need another somber right now
all right we're ready
we're probably not
but
let's go
so you said mowgwin is weak to bleat
Moog is weak to bleed and lightning we
have both of those
but Godwin died Godwin is not dead
his spirit is dead
his body is alive
just like Ronnie's body is dead but her
spirit is alive
but Godwin is not dead
I'll turn up the music as well
it sounds like a toilet
foreign
not lightning that was telling me
Lightning this whole [ __ ] time
[ __ ] you must abide alone a while
Moog is weak to dying good good
welcome honored the guest what's good
versus plassy to that birthplace
maybe we'll use like beastial sling
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
he's gonna get it all back right here so
[ __ ] it
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that was going so well
uh until it didn't
wow
that was fast I don't even know what
happened what happened
I think I got hit and died
I got humbled holy [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
bleed already
big
no please get in there nice
nice
foreigners
[ __ ]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
it's mine and mine alone
you know what I'm realizing I'm really
good at fighting Moog holy [ __ ]
you know and you know if I had some
Vigor he'd be dead
watch this though
I should not have used bloodhound's
finesse like that one dude in chat told
me to when I peeked over and said dude
spam it and then I died it's your fault
not mine
[Music]
that's right
that was my bad
[Music]
[Music]
I'm fighting bad him
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
no no no no
oh my God
[ __ ] man
I got mowed
I got hit with the damn Fire Man brig
no
[Music]
[Music]
that's right
I'm lucky oh unlucky right there
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
bleed yeah yeah
[Music]
no it broke it there was some fire
foreign
no protection this time
okay okay
[Music]
[Music]
we've clearly got this Austin thanks for
becoming a tarnish man
make sure to join the Discord and thank
you very much
do we clearly [ __ ] got this bro we
got this dude
it's so apparent we got this
we are actually killing it right now
[Music]
[Music]
Drive
green but we did it
huge amount of grade there wow
whoa
[Music]
double bleed
just keep hitting him
come on nice no
it's me man
[Music]
is mine and mine alone no
that was a lot of unlucky things to
happen right there that was a lot of
unlucky things I thought he couldn't
reach me I thought I was completely out
of range and he still got me bro
he still got me
[ __ ] I don't think I picked these up
either I did okay
[Music]
crazy
[Music]
why is my audio
no
that hurt
[Music]
that was my fault
[Music]
whatever
the best not the worst
please
way too greedy
way too greedy this is not good
why am I doing that
what that hit me
[Music]
get me off the stairs man
he wants me on the stairs
[Applause]
thank you
let's go holy [ __ ] oh let's go yes
[Music]
damn
oh
the Dodge is at the end bro the Dodges
were so good
oh
that fight is [ __ ] awesome dude I I
used to hate Moog and when I once I
figured out Moog like how to dodge a lot
of his attacks
I love the fight now it's it's a lot of
fun
wait we have five
spins holy [ __ ] wait we'll have more
man let's go
laughs
the FBI physic we needed it man it's
part of the game
oh next to the C thank you bro
thank you man good stuff get some W's
after barbarians
I mean I don't know if it's gonna be
barbarians I have no idea what the DLC
is going to be X
it's gonna be good though that's all I
know man but thank you for the 20 get
some W's in chat appreciate that support
that's very kind of you thank you thank
you thank you thank you thank you
I hope you're having a good New Year's
man
thank you thank you thank you
guys make sure to like the stream man
good shot also hope you and everyone had
a great New Year's I did man hope you
did too thank you for the 10 W's in the
chat for Trump and X for Trump for pump
NX thank you thank you guys
I really appreciate it
dude that felt so good to get that done
like somewhat early oh my God that felt
good
I didn't I didn't know I was that good
against Moog like I'm not gonna lie like
I felt so confident
man let's go okay
chat like the stream do it now now
okay here we go
how many levels do we have now
still five
okay
wait
okay
spin number one
that's okay it's a little painful but
it's okay it'll help us with our bleed
in some some way out there
strength again
strength is I've been our big boy
strength has been our big boy
all good
endurance
I almost did mine again how do I buy
members I'm sorry so dumb how do you buy
members
uh make sure you have it enabled
it should just be down below at the
bottom of the chat bro
and thank you for the two dollars Austin
appreciate it
[Applause]
uh Esther thank you too man
wait wait
Esther appreciate I think I don't know
what the currency is but I appreciate
the super sticker thank you guys
appreciate it appreciate it wait what
did we land on
did I already do Arcane yeah I did we
have one more spin
one more spinny spin
but thank you guys
buy another Lance here and for more
Vigor apparently oh [ __ ] okay
35 strength
[Applause]
okay
okay
boom
oh Hong Kong dollars gotcha well I
appreciate it thank you I have not seen
that currency before
or at least I don't remember it okay
this is actually turned into a glass
Cannon build it really is glass Cannon
for real for real
so you guys are saying lightning is good
against placidusex
or fire is
whatever it is we're going there next
what's popping metal babe how we doing
Happy New Year to you
guys notice I'm not wearing a hat today
look at me go
maybe that was the problem why am I here
we go
lightning is good for Dragons that's so
strange
I think the roulette might need to be
closed and open again it's getting to
the same specs
I mean it's still completely random it
definitely doesn't need to be open and
closed
y'all just don't like what we're getting
we're we're finally having a good day
with the specs
finally
took three days
many hours
[Music]
only thing I don't like about this fight
is the run back okay
that hurt
oh I should have changed my physics
for the dope Street you're welcome
and thank you for the five dollars
thanks for all the super chats guys
I appreciate it thank you
how painful was this
we were getting one shot last time we
tried to do this
like we weren't even remotely close to
beating plastic new sex
but thank you uh integral
awful starting here waking up with a
cold and got my period that is not very
poggers medal I am sorry
but hopefully you feel better soon
they should have put a steak America
here yeah
I think if they if you found it you
should have had one
yeah
yeah
skip
I really should have changed my physics
we'll live for now
we'll live for now let's go
come on
this plastidusax bleed
[Music]
at least we're not getting one shot now
that's good
[Music]
come on
guys lightning was not very good there
that wasn't good
it did like 200 damage
it did like 200 [ __ ] damage I'm using
scorching black Flame
at least we're not getting one shot
because your seals plus nine oh yeah
through physics
where would I be without you you know
what we're doing it without it I don't
want to wait for the elevator I don't
wanna
also I will forget again I will
I will forget
so just be ready for that
and don't get mad at me even though it's
my fault
right
it's probably faster to die than the
weight I don't know with this run back
hug his butt charge the Dragon Lightning
attack Dragon Cult seal and offhand
golden bow okay that's a lot
[ __ ] we don't have
he's resistant to all all elements
and what you know what you know what I'm
gonna do chat I'm just gonna hit him
with my big
you know what
and he'll die
right
[Music]
that's good potato
way better way better
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
what
thank you Brent I didn't even hear it
I'm sorry
[Applause]
get hot [ __ ]
[Music]
fire
nice
he's gonna drop yep there we go
good
imagine getting hit by that tail
couldn't be me
that was kind of [ __ ] knocking a cap
[Music]
Get Wrecked
[Music]
okay
right
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] calling it now
foreign
[Music]
there it is
give me that come on [ __ ]
[Music]
this is going well
[Music]
come on
[Music]
I'm done I'm alive
huh
oh I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead
[Music]
that's that's so [ __ ] lame ah all
right I didn't forget
how do you
what is how do you avoid that attack
chat
[Music]
how do you do it
do you just have to dodge at the right
time
and that's it
enhances charged attacks that makes
sense
run towards him as fast as you can
really
I've always ran away so maybe that that
means that
no I'm not using summons Austin
buy that attack too
I'm not gonna make him land near the
wall that's not gonna happen
so run towards him
are we positive on that
that sounds terrifying
hot physic when he does that
I think you're right just in case we do
yeah
I avoid that by adding tons of vigor
I'm staring at you
if you're fast enough you can be under
the raise
I don't think I think Bloodhounds Fang
just using it in general is our best bet
I don't feel like the black flame really
does all that much
and if we just hit him enough we can
stagger him I'm just going to use
Bloodhound swing
[Music]
that doesn't help either
[Music]
[Music]
don't block me
thank you I'm just gonna hit him there
we go
just so I don't get one shot I
[Music]
shot [ __ ] you
so [ __ ] good holy crap
[Music]
I've never been hit by the [ __ ] tail
man
[Music]
ever
that's embarrassing
I just don't want to get one shot
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he might no
[Music]
[Music]
what's he doing
[Music]
great run touring
that's why we used it
stop
for the love of God
[Music]
guys easier said than done in the moment
no no no no no
no please please please
so that's so [ __ ] unlucky dude I
can't see his head so I didn't know what
he was doing [ __ ] man
that's so unlucky
I even dodged the first part of it
skill issue
uh we got that bleed off too man oh my
God
all right next question I have has
everybody liked the stream yet
does everybody like the stream yet
if you haven't
kind of a turd
I think we have more likes than viewers
right now I don't know
uh
you get more viewers by getting more
likes
the goal by the end of the year is to
have 5 000 likes on a stream with over 5
000 viewers
that's the goal
we are very far from that
we can do it
very far
we like the stream okay good
you better
we can clearly do this though
[Music]
very clearly
this tail almost caught me there what is
that what was the
question
what
was that
the fabled wing attack
bruh
um yup
yep
bunker
just block
shut up Mike
now
that's annoying
we're regressing
the regressing has started
I'm not gonna dual wield
this is not Dark Souls 2.
foreign
fingers butthole
thank you
I need to stop making fun of the the
tail
[Music]
[Music]
I'm gonna get caught aren't I
yes
[Music]
how is moog easier than this
no his wing killed me
I just wish there wasn't this run back
so where should I stand when I'm hitting
him should I actually stand in front of
him
is there only one side of his wing or
does he use both wings
do I just have to hit his tail the
entire fight
like just go right for the [ __ ]
okay
[Music]
that's a bit unlucky
click right here
[Music]
[Music]
this dick and twisted
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
what the [ __ ] was that
I didn't even see fire near my this like
anywhere close to me
[Music]
[Music]
what the what do I do about this
what do I do about that attack
[Music]
I'm finessing his face
way better
okay we only got one though
[Music]
huh
[Music]
yeah run toward him right
I'm never doing that again
I immediately started running toward him
and there's no [ __ ] shot whatever
oh
oh never mind
who was saying runs towards many people
in the chat room
many people
you gotta told you front roll dude like
if if I have to dodge it anyway why am I
running toward the [ __ ] lasers that
are like connecting together when I'm
closer
jump over the laser okay I'm done
reading Chad I'm done I'm done
I'm not reading it anymore
nope
not reading it
you lost it
you lost the streamer
foreign
I'm not reading never mind
how the [ __ ] do you get behind them when
I'm running
shut up
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
different now
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I don't know why I'm randomly getting
hit by that
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I couldn't find them
he wasn't in the sky
he wasn't there
[ __ ] my ass
Trump thank you for the five dollars
and the chat of morbin time I appreciate
that thank you very much
chat why am I getting hit by the the
lightning aerial attack
the second time he does it twice in a
row what am I doing wrong
I always just roll through it I've done
that twice and gotten hit twice
why am I getting hit
is there something I have to do
specifically
with that attack that's different from
the other time he does it
I'm not using dragon's grease it does
not make a difference I promise
I don't have Bloodhound step
okay
okay
I was gonna bring chat back in the
equation but now I'm not gonna
is your mean
you're mean to me
[Music]
come on man no
[Music]
piss
[Music]
Ed
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
can't I find him man
he's gonna dash of that time
[Music]
his tele
[Music]
what just happened
his teleport killed me and then he
appeared
I I literally just died like there was
no [ __ ] reason
his teleport does no damage
half my body got stuck in the teleport
did you see him just reappear like he
just went
yeah it has not done the nuke attack
once
not a single nuke
that was a I literally died to a glitch
I think that was a glitch that was
literally a glitch
that was a glitch
glitch not my fault glitch
unlucky
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm not using Bloodhound step
[Music]
thank you for the five I appreciate it
thank you but I'm not I'm not using
Bloodhound stuff
[Music]
nice
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
together
my two-year-old cheering you on
thank you Austin's two-year-old I
appreciate the two dollars
Alex thank you again for the five
Trump thank you again for the five I'm
not going to use Bloodhound step I'm not
going to use all the suggestions you
guys are saying in the chat I'm not
gonna do it we've almost killed him
twice
just let me do it like this calm down
and when I die I want y'all to say Jake
l
okay
no more back seating
it will happen eventually
but just calm down okay and then I'll
calm down
thank you
just say Jake L when I die okay that's
what I want
[Music]
thank you
you've got this man we believe in you
what I believe in myself too Alex and
thank you for another five I really
appreciate it thank you thank you
thank you thank you
yep Jake l
that's our that's gonna be our emote we
have another emote idea it's Jake l
maybe even a jake w
a very rare Jake w
ow there you go stair L perfect
we got this
hi Logan we believe in the Bonk the
balkaning takes time it does take time
we can clearly do it like this
we got it
so annoying
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
oh no
dude
I literally see the wing and I just die
oh no
I see the wing and just know I'm dead
oh
[ __ ]
I watched it in slow-mo too I literally
looked at it and said no
please
is there just like a timed roll on that
one guys
I have yet to dodge the [ __ ] wing
I've yet to dodge it you know what you
have yet to do probably some of you
you have yet to like the Stream
go ahead and do so if you haven't
already
more likes equals more viewers
we're trying to get to 5 000 likes on a
stream at some point this year more
likes equals more views which equals
more likes which equal more views
thank you very much
if you have already thanked
Shields I don't know about I don't use
Shields
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
I'm gonna go ahead and say
that I think that attack is a little
broken
I don't understand what's hitting me
there
it looks like the wing
but he's not doing a wing attack
oh
no advice to give acceptance here the
Peace of all that is tarnished a new one
from all of us who have suffered from
him and his BS you got this my guy beat
him up give Jake a w guys
yeah Chad give me a w
Jake W for once
Rick thank you very much man I
appreciate the uh the 10 super chat
thank you
and happy New Year to y'all
I'm gonna get this I'm gonna [ __ ] do
it
I can do it
and then we have to go through the Haley
tree and then we have to go fight
Melania oh God okay let's not think
about that yet
this wing attack is killer
I'll earn that W I will earn the w
ow no I [ __ ] up
[Music]
[Music]
whoa
whoa
[Music]
hurts nuke Run please
literally coolest attack in the game
[Music]
[Music]
I don't know I got
potato thank you not for the L but for
the two dollars thanks man
[Music]
run out run out run out oh
foreign
thing about this Dragon just kills me
oh quickly
just a One-Shot Factory not even mode
one shot me well
space two he did
okay radon's meteor is probably the
coolest attack in the game but the nuke
is very close
I mean this Dragon like flaps his wing
in my face and I die
sometimes you know twice now where it's
not even an attack it's just there
the God damn
I got damn attack
you're welcome radagon
wait Steve let's go with the five gifted
members
W's in the chat for Twisted L's in the
chat for Jake
as per usual
Twisted thank you very much for the five
gifted I really do appreciate that thank
you very much
welcome new members
hello make sure to think Twisted when
you get a chance
[Music]
I got this
[Music]
[Music]
I don't really know what he's gonna do
here
[Music]
uh I'm just gonna keep hitting him maybe
hope for a bleed I don't think I can get
to his head that's an L that's an L well
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here's a better View
I like how the Music Stops
so cool
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
that's new
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
got to be close to something bleed right
there bleed
we'll take it we'll take it
I don't know why I'm randomly getting
hit by that attack now I don't know
what's going on with that
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yeah I like my way of dealing with that
come on just give me normal attacks
[Music]
come on close to something
give me that normal
left-hander yep
and then fire
why is it randomly closer
foreign
[Music]
nice
did I earn my W's I did I see W's now
thank you
I earned my W's
you gotta earn the W's out here
good fight good [ __ ] good stuff
good stuff boys
let's see
we got some spinny spins coming up baby
yup first try exactly thank you for
saying that makes me feel a little
better okay
three levels acquired ladies and
gentlemen three whole levels
here we go let's see what we get hope
for Vigor honestly at this point it
doesn't make a [ __ ] difference so who
cares what we get I don't even mind
getting decks Dex is good we will take
decks
one of three spin number two
yep we're gonna go fight Melania now
oh Give Me Faith No not int uh whatever
last spin last spin
it's a good day out here we at least
have 25 bigger guys at least have 25 we
will take that every day of the week
what a great day to be here right now
what a great freaking day man okay
now
again if you haven't liked the stream go
ahead and do it now because uh I don't
think we're gonna like the stream for a
while after fighting
Melania blade of maquella for as long as
we're gonna have to and we have to go
through the [ __ ] hailing tree now
so let's go
yeah I know you did Mike but maybe
someone out there didn't okay
possible
let's get it let's go
[Music]
almost fell
almost fell
Yep this is going to be a real fun time
getting through here
it's just Melania radagon and Eldon B's
left right guys I think that's it
don't die to Bubbles that'd be
embarrassing what bubbles oh God just
kidding I knew those were coming
ah
I don't even count Loretta
Loretta's Dead first [ __ ] try
now I'm mad
[Music]
humongous L you could say
biggest l
at what's the skip
isn't there a skip
or did they did they patch the skip
for this entire area I don't know I
think it's the entire area
[Music]
didn't I didn't die
save your elves for next time
because I didn't [ __ ] die
those bubbles blow
you could say that
you could say that
say that you can Parry them if begotten
and fall off to the elevator
okay not that
oh asking us for help thought we need to
shut up but Tater you know what I mean
when I'm in the middle of a boss fight
and y'all are like use this use that
that's not the help I'm referring to
that's back seating
foreign
big difference
humongous difference
also I think it was wrong
[Music]
the 18
trunk
[ __ ] this area
still exactly as I say
la la la la la la
so you do want us to help that [ __ ] no
whatever dude whatever dude
y'all don't want to understand what I'm
saying fine
y'all don't get it that's fine
I guess if you want the help
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh wait
yeah yeah
we're good
we were moving through there you could
say
I could have just sent it up
I'm not back seat the [ __ ]
the [ __ ]
I have a theory I think the Albany
Oregon Dynasty were misled thinking they
were there at the hail tree because
they're two portals of the snow field
Maybe
it's a good theory
[Music]
I'm using blast and displayed
Jake l
Jake L uh Jake L Jake L Jake l
[Music]
what happened to first try
what happened
what happened to the first try gee
um what happened
what happened to first try low
LOL you said first try LOL and then you
die oh my God
oh my God
he said he'd first try and then he died
long
oh my God
imagine
couldn't be me
LOL
whoa I'm done
the hell
stop it
foreign
you can't Dismount Loretta I'm pretty
sure
you sound like that Grandpa from Family
Guy
yes give me a little just give me his
hat that's all I want just give me his
hat I just want to snip it
that's all I want is to sniff his hat
that's it
that one
foreign
[Music]
Ty looks like without the helmet on
foreign
man I am going into slight Madness right
now
it's happening
you're trash
good one Betty
[Music]
I didn't think Loretta would be this
hard I'm not gonna lie but true
foreign
[Music]
ah
okay Logan
owie
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
it's just one challenge after the next
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
tomorrow
I thought she already shot a man
I thought they already went
TJ
tell me to use lightning strike again
and I want you to see what happens when
you do
it
do it
do it
okay
okay
give it a try
I'll try I'll try this
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thought I might get lucky with something
there
I did not
[Music]
I'm stuck on the horse
foreign
[Music]
foreign
just just quite literally
any other attack
any other attack she does there and I
win but she did that one
specifically that try that attack killed
me excellent that sucks I did not enjoy
what just happened I didn't like that I
don't I don't like that that sucked that
wasn't fun
I prefer if I won
and not died
I prefer that
instead
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I thought she'd do
something other than keep swinging
he didn't he kept swinging
instead
of what I thought she did
just to think Melania is after this
I mean
foreign
[ __ ]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
okay sure
okay
sure
sure
[Music]
sure
can I get some sure
stirs in the chat
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
she tried to end the fight right there
foreign
on this okay
okay
why didn't I roll
laughs
[Music]
what is going on
every time she does the perfect
counter-attack to what I do every time
man
holy [ __ ] the timing is unreal
[ __ ]
oh my goodness
oh my
he's hard
you just did that
foreign
[Music]
scares me a lot
foreign
like spasm in the sky what the [ __ ] was
that
[Music]
no okay
cheeky
[ __ ]
first try not even a hard boss
not even a difficult boss at all really
not
first try
[Music]
foreign
Pro Gamer
all right
two spins two
singular
spinny spins
ladies and gentlemen here we go boom
level 120 by the way
nah
[Applause]
but not bigger
not the gooder and mind excellent okay
not to ruin the mood but melania's next
go ahead and hit you with an ad for
saying that one Benny thank you all
right
gotcha okay
next getting through the halog tree
then Melania
yeah we're definitely using Blasphemous
blade against her 100 I think that will
definitely be better against her
you can beat her first try I believe in
you
if I beat Melania first try on this
challenge
I think I should be considered the best
player in the world
foreign
what games are you excited for over next
year
um
nothing in particular
I just hope some good fun games come out
yeah we have our weapons Bob we don't
need it we are using the weapons we have
how does this work
um
Alden ring DLC right that's yep that's
the only game I'm looking forward to
you'll donate a hundred Super Chat I'm
not gonna beat her so that's a great bet
you all make bets because I'm not gonna
beat her first try it's just not gonna
happen
there ain't no [ __ ] way Jose
[Music]
oh
what
so he just doubled up that attack
he just did it twice
went bang bang bang bang
interesting
this is why we burned down the air tree
okay
great Shield Talisman we already have it
did I use it
for Melania
oh yeah we should burn the Halo tree
down I'm dead
okay just just get me to Millennia so I
don't have so I can focus on her okay
oh the great the great Shield Talisman
where is that
the top of the chapel you jump into
if I see it I grab it
easy as that
[ __ ] off
all of you
I went the wrong way I went the wrong
way I went the wrong way
I don't know where to go man no
ah please
not here not like this not like this
go go go
oh God
[ __ ] revenants
holy
scarier than Melania like no cap on a
stack bro no cap literally scarier than
Melania
just don't just don't just don't [ __ ] me
over don't do it I'm right here thank
you
I'm fine with death now
there it is
what's this okay
I think revenants are the true horror of
the game I I never want to be near them
I never want to touch them I don't want
anything to do with them
[Music]
all right this is beautiful though this
right here is so [ __ ] cool
you know the area sucks like I just run
through here every time but it looks
beautiful
all right how many attempts are we
guessing on millennia
oh [ __ ]
really yeah
here we go here come all the suggestions
to avoid doing what I'm doing here they
come
oh boy
let me just do this
eat
anyone saying single digits you're
insane
Quick Step
hey look at that we got through there
now you don't have to
foreign
just fly
the answer is yes exactly good answer
good answer
yes
okay do I have like any runes before now
that's not gonna get us there okay well
we have what we have we're honestly a
high enough level to beat the entire
game and I think even beating Melania so
we don't really have to level anymore
but we will if we can because that's the
entire challenge
challenge okay
I'm going in the chapel it's at the top
though right how do I get to the top of
the chapel is it up there
how important is this Talisman like is
it really gonna help us
how the [ __ ] do I get in there
is it in that chest
[Music]
I mean that beam looks Out Of Reach
isn't it
left side
ah thank you
all right
Yep
this is a great area
the Haley tree is like a lot of fun
how many attempts at chest
it's worth it okay
okay
foreign
[Music]
Mimi's home
[Music]
lightning strike
good suggestion
it's something
sometimes
like playing
oh it fell that's big
okay
okay we'll take a little look
okay how how good is this
enormously boosts physical damage
negation
what do we traded for we have green
turtle Talisman radagon Source seal
archery favor plus one and two fingers
heirloom
we're gonna use faith for
the Blasphemous blade against Melania
did I still trade it
sorcile gives us levels in health so I
don't think we well and then a bunch of
other stuff too
guys I don't think we should trade the
source seal well it's against Melania so
yeah we should actually
foreign
extra health
stamina booster doesn't even help
properly you think so
and try some stuff out
are you guys ready for this I'm not I'll
tell you that right now I'm not I'm not
ready for this
um we gonna find out though
here we go
if she attacks right at the end of the
cutscene I remember
I dreamed for so long
foreign
was dull gold and my blood rotted
corpse after corpse left in my wake
as I waited
is returned
heed my words
I am Melania
blade of mikola
and I have never known defeat
who asked
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
that kind of sucks
It's gotta be a little closer
[Music]
why do I feel slower
like I feel like my character literally
isn't moving as fast as it usually does
is that because of the stamina thing
the stamina Talisman I took off
am I medium low because it's a different
sword
[Music]
whoa
foreign
[Music]
blade
[Music]
I feel like this Dragon thing Talisman
is not worth it at all
my character actually feels less heavy
all right
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
blade of
I'm going to say this now
real quick
and Trey I give you full permission
to time out people
for trying to tell me how to dodge the
waterfowl
and this is like three two three
attempts chat
do not tell me to throw pots
to dodge into it to do any of that [ __ ]
I'm telling you right [ __ ] now don't
start you will get instantly timed out
and then if you keep going you're going
to get banned just shut up and say Jake
L thank you
just throwing that out there real early
I tried to turn around
I like went back and then tried to Dodge
in by yeah that was bad
Jake L there you go
boom
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
video
[Music]
Jake needs Good Vibes no iTunes good
luck Jay
[Music]
[Music]
oh Bolivia
blade of me so unlucky
I got thrown off when I
uh he tried to grab and I staggered her
I got thrown off I dodged too many times
angel thank you I yes that's true good
message thank you man
yeah it was almost perfect I always
dodged the last one the wrong direction
I struggle with it a lot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
I just got surprised I got hit I thought
I dodged that perfectly and it still hit
me the first one
oh my god dude we're dying so [ __ ]
fast oh my God it is
wow this this might be [ __ ]
unbelievably hard chat oh my goodness
[Music]
what
no the Run back's good
[Music]
I'm
lucky
[Music]
let's go
bad timing on that one zeta thank you
for the five I appreciate that uh I let
you down I'm sorry
[Laughter]
thank you thank you appreciate it
come on
[Music]
do you really want to be the one
dreading the family Legacy yes
[Music]
trips thank you for the five I
appreciate it man thank you thank you
I'm dead
[Music]
no
I just don't know where to go on that
one man
thank you drips and Zeta oh and twisted
with the five Gifted Man let's go
thanks dude
that's the Melania alert too thank you
man
I appreciate you guys I'm
oh I'm already humbled which I think is
a good thing I think it's good that I'm
already humbled I haven't fought Melania
in a while
every time I do it's a [ __ ] five hour
ordeal thank you guys
if you got a gifted from Twisted make
sure to say thank you man
[Music]
got to be close to a stagger after that
yeah
I tried I didn't think she'd do it [ __ ]
I didn't think she'd go for it that
early man
I thought she'd stagger too yeah yeah
bro
I don't know if the health back with the
Blasphemous player chat is worth it
because we just die so quick
and she kind of dodges out of the way of
it
I don't know
[Music]
where did I get hit
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now she definitely can
[Music]
[Music]
what
why is your pulleys so weird
foreign
he looks like she's in the mood
for it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so [ __ ] stupid
[Music]
Blasphemous blade is definitely another
weapon I need to use it right
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
very good very good first face
could have used a little less health
a little less blue
Maybe
that was good did I get hit
yes I definitely did
that's a good sign that's actually a
really really good sign
we might want to add another blue flask
because when she does that
the bloom attack Blasphemous blade is
going to be huge for us yeah
[Applause]
blooming onion
[Music]
flowers once
[Music]
we could do that Miro yeah we can
I probably should
[Music]
change
[Music]
a wickedly hard thing to dodge off the
rip there man
she just busted that one out right there
man
one of her [ __ ] clones one hits me
dude
one hit from her cologne kills me
how many how many more blue Flats did I
have there I wasn't even looking
that sucks man that sucks
we got it let's try a 7-3 see a
difference
yep Shadow clone Jutsu
yeah we have enough mine to where we can
get off a lot of shots fall through
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
idiot
I should have died
my backstabber yeah
I treat her like radagon where you can't
[Music]
nice
that's unlucky
[Music]
take it let's chill
[Music]
if you're close enough it will hit her
to know
[ __ ]
why how could I do this
[Music]
[Music]
good
that's chill
[Music]
[Music]
we're figuring her out
let's go
[Music]
no way
she can just whip that out whenever she
wants man
foreign I mean she can just like she
just went out of an attack and just went
it's impossible to know stage two when
she like might just whip that dick out
man dude
I think that was just kind of unlucky
but
we're clearly doing pretty good if we've
gotten to stage two twice we can do it
[Music]
we'll take it
I should have ran
no I shouldn't have
[Music]
it's unlucky we ran out of a wall
really unlucky
Millennia got the biggest hate boner for
the tarnished apparently
I'm like a I'm basically at this point
like 99 convinced that she's completely
blind and that's why her attacks are so
crazy but she doesn't really know
where she's attacking or what she's
attacking but she can like hear it like
she's that good of a swordsman that's
why there's water in the arena
been blind
it'd be so cool if you could like use
the
assassin's Veil be invisible and she
can't see you that'd be so cool
all right
that was uh
[Music]
not a good attempt she is you can see
her face yeah I know Rob the games
you know there's lots of things that can
see and then they don't like you know
their shit's covered or whatever it it
doesn't mean that she's blind but I
think she is
yeah cannonly I think it's Canon it
doesn't say it anywhere
but I think she is
[Music]
that was my bad
foreign
you see this that makes me think she's
blind that right there
not giving me the best RNG in the world
right now
[Music]
like I said that's really unlucky she
didn't get staggered because I don't
under her Poise makes no sense at all
her pull is actually makes zero sense I
I don't get it she'll get staggered by
one attack one time and then another
time it doesn't
care
so she's a blind triple paraplegic with
a crippling disease yep and she's that
strong imagine Melania if she didn't
have any of this stuff can you [ __ ]
imagine how strong she'd be
imagine however strong radon would be
if you if we didn't fight him the way he
is now
it's delay
[Music]
chicken waterfowl here right yep
I'm crouched
[Music]
I I pressed in my stick too hard when I
turned around dude
I am rotasi
blessing of nicolasi
and I have never known to fussy
hope I can help munchie
[Music]
[Music]
in Romania
blade I don't think I had stamina
you're fighting a [ __ ] at her weakest
I mean
these handicapped for sure yeah
everyone in the game's handicapped
in some way
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
ow
[Music]
so unlucky that my tracking goes when
she goes around me like that and
sometimes I just go right into it that
just sucks
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I just my character just didn't roll I
don't I wasn't looking at stamina I
guess I don't know it just didn't roll
melania's at her prime
I don't think so at all
foreign
I think she's at her prime as The Rock
goddess yeah but not as a Swordsman
[Music]
[Music]
what
dude that made no sense what the [ __ ]
now
greater will equals flame of frenzy over
rots
how she got beaten up by radon because
radon's probably stronger than her
but she has to use her rot [ __ ] to even
[ __ ] him
[Music]
foreign
such good attempts and now we're not
[Music]
[Music]
urine oh became a demigod God damn
that's way up there urine
thank you so much holy [ __ ] dude
thank you thank you
welcome dude W's in the chat for a year
in
demigod that's a big membership that's
way up there thank you dude
holy
not what I wanted to do
it I didn't I didn't even mean to press
left trigger dude you
mistake equals Death that's the fight
mistake equals dead
thank you thank you urine that is huge
don't forget to hydrate
yo dude I don't have water [ __ ] I might
have to go get one
I don't want to get out of the
my mode here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I got lucky she didn't waterfowl
[Music]
real lucky
[Music]
[Music]
there you are
foreign
she was extremely aggro that time man
holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
he was Non-Stop
is godric disabled or is he just cringe
well I he did it to himself
so I don't know he's definitely stronger
than his like normal self kind of like
Reichard
I would imagine
I'd say reichard's at his strongest
godric's had his strongest MOG is that
his strongest
probably more gots at his strongest than
everyone else is disabled in some way
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
far
yep
saw that coming
we go around beating up cripples it
kinda yeah we kind of do
who else would be at their strongest
I think Mo like Melania as The Rock
goddess yeah she's as strong as she can
be because I don't think she can bloom
again after she blooms against us
um
not as strong as a swordsman though like
our first stage she's not as strong as
she could be he's I think [ __ ] blind
um
phrey's handicapped until he turns into
horror Lou
which that might be preference but he
literally rips off his handicap to fight
us
Mug's at his strongest
[Music]
I'm getting real unlucky here sometimes
[Music]
can't make a mistake dude can't
you can Bloom as many times as she wants
I guess so yeah I guess so
I would say Godfrey's probably not in
his prime
since
probably a bit older
I don't know if age has anything to do
with it I don't I don't know
fire giant is definitely handicapped
[Music]
[Music]
little unlucky
that's like a non whatever
I just hate that attack there's really
no reason I just don't like it
[Music]
oh
[Music]
my God
foreign
[Music]
do we know specifically how long an age
ago is because that's kind of the only
like amount of time frame that we're
given
we know the shattering happened a very
long time ago I don't know if it's 5 000
years or if an age means 5 000 or a
thousand I have no idea how long an age
ago means especially in this world like
maybe it means something else
[Music]
[Music]
risky whiskey boys
nope that's not good I'm dead
[Music]
blade
George R Martin said the shattering took
place over a 5 000 year period he said
he said that in an interview okay then
that would that would there you go
five thousand years
that's a long [ __ ] time man
the power of gravity and I choose to
graft animals like roomberry lobsters
Dragon of course not tarnish
I mean he does grab the dragon at the
end true
maybe it feels different
[Music]
[Music]
no
knew it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
that's not good
I think the hill just saved me somewhat
calm down lady
[Music]
foreign
dancing
[Music]
[Music]
knock her out
[Music]
three times in the first phase is super
unlucky
we survived twice though that's pretty
good
I mean when she's gonna go for that
three times in one phase that's straight
up just being
very hard to tell
very hard to live
I can't believe some people were like oh
my game crashed wow bro
thank you
it crashed dude
this happens at such odd times like out
of nowhere
close program I guess damn dude
pain
play
yeah and lighten these nuts
we always have one crash
oh I feel like we're we were doing so
much better earlier and now we're like
can't even get to stage two
foreign
you know what I feel like what we can
say in the lore
do we need a specific amount here here's
the question do we need to know the
specific amount of time that's passed
since the shattering
not really
it's a long [ __ ] time ago and I think
that's all we need to know it's a long
time ago we you know it's not like five
years ago but yeah it just doesn't
matter you know it straight up doesn't
matter
foreign
[Music]
way too risky
[Music]
that would be cool Hugh that would be
pretty cool however he does say
you're not fit even to graft so he
doesn't even want to graft you so that
also makes sense that he doesn't
yeah yeah
it's a long [ __ ] time ago chat
it's not like to the dinosaurs for us or
whatever
okay Trey okay
Peru bro
well
unlucky
[Music]
[ __ ]
my elenia true
I mean there's no way I was getting away
from that so I didn't even try
there's no way I was going to run away
[Music]
Blasphemous blade keeps killing you no
it doesn't
Melania keeps stealing me
man oh man oh my god dude
Jesus Christ
just you know
she did that a couple of times and now I
am dead
and I asked why I've unsubscribed but
keep getting your notifications like
crazy figure out the Channel please
later
why did you unsubscribe what's wrong
jeez calm down buddy
[Music]
I don't think that's my fault you
[ __ ] idiot what a [ __ ]
foreign
[Music]
why did Stephen even say that what
happened
Steven was chill
great unban them I want to hear what he
had to say I'm I'm curious
what the [ __ ] happened
[Music]
[Music]
it's probably not here anymore but I'm
just curious what happened for him to
feel that way
foreign
Marcus shut your [ __ ] mouth you have
no idea what's going on
[Music]
[Music]
blade Jesus
what happened Stephen what's going on
man
[Music]
Marcus I can tell he's a troll I don't
know about Steven yet though
it's gone man it's literally the first
day of the year and you're already like
coming into chat rooms and just like
being weird like what's going on dude
[Music]
[Music]
why I do that
risky should not have done that
literally let's go
thanks man
appreciate the five gifted members
appreciate you very much
LOL that's all I need to hear have a
great year you guys
what I'm literally asking why you're mad
why you wanted to unsub
I'm asking you like personally what
happened
like last I heard you were like chilling
and chat having a good time and now
you're all like
you wanting on sub and getting mad that
you got a notification that I exist what
the [ __ ]
all right
and you won't answer
you're just being shitty I don't
understand why but Ludwig thank you man
I appreciate you dude W's and chat for
looty
Mr Ludwig
[Music]
before
[Music]
it might have been as far as I could go
there
let's get away from that
I don't like being right in the middle
it'll be okay
yep she was baiting me so hard
I have to dodge later
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
don't ask why I went for three there bro
thank you
[Music]
hi Emily that hurts blade oh and then
she just jumps
[ __ ] dude
um
okay I guess just ban Stephen I don't I
don't know why you won't answer I guess
you had a bad night or has had a bad
year I don't know
actually don't ban him maybe he'll come
back and not be a dick
you never know why someone's an [ __ ]
bro especially someone that wasn't an
[ __ ] for at least a week
I don't know maybe he had a bad day
I don't know
I'm moving on and I'm gonna fight
Millennia though let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm learning this distance I need
foreign
[Music]
God that attack is so [ __ ] annoying
all right
why is he need to be an [ __ ] I don't
know you never know bro like
the only reason I'm not going to ban him
or like not just like get rid of them
immediately is because he was chill for
literally a week
like really cool dude in the chat and
then all of a sudden he's coming in here
like that that makes me think something
happened if I had never seen his name
ever like the other dude we banned then
we just get rid of him like that's just
[ __ ] weird but
you know I asked a couple times didn't
want to answer that's whatever he can
come back if he wants to someday clearly
right now he doesn't want to for
whatever reason
but it is what it is
good
no it's very weird but welcome to the
internet you know
yeah it could be a misunderstanding
that's why I asked him but he didn't
want to
that's true that too man exactly
good example
so she doesn't stagger from the uh the
ash of War it seems like
I need to get back in the flow here
yep never know what people are going
through but if you're just gonna come in
and Troll and be an [ __ ] like right
away like I've never even seen you
before we will quickly just get rid of
you that's just weird
but it's whatever
we've been on Millennia for a while it
we will for a while
we need the Run
[Music]
nice
so I'm gonna focus on hitting her
like regular attacks so we can get that
stagger in phase one
phase two I think we're gonna rely on
our Ash of War a lot take his flames
what do I do when she wraps around me
after I roll is that just unlucky
because if I'm too near a wall she'll
wrap around and still hit me even though
I Dodge in
I think that's just [ __ ]
I don't know
I guess [ __ ]
where does she does do like other weird
[ __ ] I don't know
I just want to get to stage two again
we were doing so good and now we're not
sucks
thank you
what
[Music]
is risky
we'll take it though
[Music]
[Music]
a little Health back
yeah this could be bad
it's fine
dumb
blade
dude if you're a certain distance
when she does that attack the it'll clip
you somewhere man it will just clip you
and then you stagger and then you get
hit by the rest and it's over [ __ ] dude
kill Melania before you die through true
true
[Music]
okay I hope I will not use a mimics here
I set it from the start I won't do it
I'm not gonna do it
[Music]
oh
give me some help
yeah yeah yeah yeah
it didn't hit her
wow
foreign
[Music]
deflect mechanics against Melania dude
that would be so fun to be able to
deflect her
someone should mod like sakuro mechanics
into Elden ring and see how it plays I
bet it's [ __ ] sick
[Music]
yeah
dude she like
did some weird [ __ ] there
he blowed it up and around me
[Music]
[Music]
nice
[Music]
calm down
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
cut out the [ __ ]
just to have
you can't risk being too close to her to
be honest
you just have to be careful because she
can just whip it out and it's over
[Music]
[Music]
unlucky
okay okay
[Music]
[ __ ] you
[Music]
bloom
[Music]
foul too
[Music]
this gets me [ __ ]
she just baited me so [ __ ] hard man
she baited me so hard
didn't do anything I wanted to do second
phase nothing at all
pain
debated
white literally debated
jaw
made it
god dude sometimes that clips into you
sucks
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
what is that [ __ ] delay man what the
[ __ ]
[Music]
but it's so dumb
she can definitely delay that attack and
it's so Random when she [ __ ] does it
man ah damn that's so annoying
y'all saw that delay right or am I just
like
through into the fight
I don't know like it could be like uh
what it what is it called
where I it feels that way but it's not
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I don't know if I agree with that one
yeah as soon as I backed up I knew I'm
dead
it can have a delay sometimes that's
what I thought it just doesn't
that timing's so important that it's I
find it odd that they even put a delay
on that attack
I guess to make her really [ __ ] hard
which she is
I find delays to be like kind of the
major essence of difficulty in Elden
ring itself too like it's so many bosses
have it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's okay
that's not
that was not
she won't waterfowl right
no
I wish there was an indicator
but she's gonna do it
I really wish there was an indicator
[Music]
maybe that'd make her too easy
oh my fault
[Music]
[Music]
I think it only seems that way there's
definitely a delay on that attack I
guarantee if we timed it there would be
a delay thousand percent
isn't the indicator when she jumps up
high
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that sucks
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I am anemia
h
I mean it's it's [ __ ] crazy that if
it's this build is so glass Cannon it's
crazy bro
ah
that was such a good fight too
it was going really good
Kirby I don't think you know what we're
talking about man
not about the super armor but the thing
before
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I got kabobbed
at least she hasn't kabobbed you great
timing on that Mr cup
that grab attack is really cool
[Music]
that was our first commodity though
[Music]
that was our first kebabing
oh man bro come on
I feel like we're close but it doesn't
look like it at all you know what I mean
I feel like we're going to rinse radagon
and Eldon or eldenbeast don't you think
foreign
guys
nice nice nice Elder Beast was the
hardest boss in my opinion
LOL
hey does that flask you use on mode does
that work for Elden stars as well
or is that a whole other thing
oh melania's Mommy for sure
definite mommy material
what the [ __ ] dude
oh my God
[Music]
a winner is a loser that never gives up
[Music]
that is true
I'm not giving up I actually feel like
my mental's pretty damn good for dying
to Melania so many times
I'm also surprised how good we were
against Moog
like we kind of annihilated mode didn't
we
Melania though
am I just bad against her or
what do you think I feel like I'm pretty
good
and maybe not though
[Music]
[Music]
that's definitely
waterfowl
health
I don't I don't get why I get hit by
that sometimes I really don't get it
I mean she backs up all the way out of
that
[Music]
I ducked it
I mean [ __ ] dude
what do I do about that she she just did
it
I practice her as often as I could just
to defeat her in less 10 less tries I
don't think I've ever defeated her
quickly
ever
it always takes me multiple hours to
beat her every time I play the game
under regular circumstances you would
have won already you're probably right
but man
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
interesting
[Music]
[Music]
that's a hundred percent a delay I don't
care what y'all say that that was
[ __ ] delayed it was
he definitely [ __ ] held that thing
my bad
why did they add delays on that dude it
makes it so insane
so like Master the movement
year and I've never been able to do that
I know you can I've never been able to
do it
no I just use OBS Celeste
OBS Studio
[Music]
[Music]
place I just didn't think she'd do that
dude I don't know
keep her away from the center of the
Arena fire damage is reduced because
it's in the water yeah that makes sense
isn't fire damage reduced when it's
raining as well
like out in the world
I think so
[Music]
it's hard to keep her out of the middle
[Music]
thank you
I'm gonna take that
I'm just gonna take that
[Applause]
Lightning's buffed
is Melania weak against lightning
[Music]
[Music]
what
blade
did that [ __ ] hit me how
[Music]
how dude how did that one
because I was going uphill
hand dude
just wake the freezing bleed
I'm gonna try lightning real quick
he's very weak to rivers of blood spam
yeah I'm sure she is I'm not gonna use
it though
uh mid
[Music]
oh yeah
if I get hit by the first one of that
attack it staggers me and I get hit by
the rest
that sucks
bleed destroyser should we try
Bloodhound Spang and just see a
different like maybe there's a
difference there I don't know because
man maybe we go Blasphemous blade stage
two
stage one Bloodhounds Fang let's try
that
this does physical and bleed so I don't
know let's [ __ ] try it
we have it
foreign
[Music]
that all that was good
[Music]
[Music]
now literally
I probably could use it or I have like
the stats for it
no way
[Music]
man calm down girl [ __ ]
foreign
you guys definitely said it and I'm just
blanking
yep answers my question
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hounds Fang stage one we are doing that
from now on for sure
absolutely
[Music]
not what I thought she'd do my bad
[Music]
[Music]
I'm gonna call that Pure Luck
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
well at least we have a plan like a
better plan
I'm not very good at switching can do I
have the
stamina to hold both of these Maybe
this one's a dual wielding earlier and
that'd just be funny
I mean [ __ ] it let's try this
[Music]
our stamina is as big as our health bar
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you see how she wraps around I really
don't know what to do about that I'm not
kidding I don't
so unlucky
[Music]
I want Health back
[Music]
[ __ ] it
um
blade of nickel
no mid-roll and light roll are
not that different I like mid-roll
mid-roll is fine
you guys can just dual wield like what
how how do you think this is gonna go
[Music]
foreign
sniping
I already don't like it
[Music]
nope
jumping L1 while dual wielding
all are making it worse with the advice
I don't know
we can clearly do it
you guys know you can use freezing pots
jumping L1
I can't jump L1 with this
look it doesn't it doesn't do it until
after
oh
okay let's do this
[Music]
that's crazy
that's weird I haven't seen that for
anything what the [ __ ]
what is she doing
that was weird
and bleed for e600 damage
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
chat
pain
that just hurts the soul
[ __ ]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
so we're just gonna do that again are
you kidding what the [ __ ] kind of luck
is that see just doubled that [ __ ] up
into a waterfowl what the [ __ ]
this luck that's all RNG
that's plain and simple RNG
[ __ ] dude I didn't want to back off like
a [ __ ] because she just did an attack I
don't like
oh man dude
time out OKO if we have a [ __ ] person
in the chat stop being cringe or a mod
in the chat stop being cringe
[Music]
oh that one got me Chad
that one got me bro
[Music]
you stop
foreign
[Music]
what did I do you're being cringed
that's what you did you're being cringe
you're being cringe
that's what you did
cringe cocoa
I wonder if Jake likes Melania
I think she's awesome
there are certain parts of melania's
fight that I don't like
but I think she's cool
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Leo stop being cringe everyone call Leo
and Coco cringe thank you just call them
cringe they're being cringe
[Music]
12.
[Music]
please
don't bait me
[Music]
come on Melania please
Melania
Melania
come on
don't do this
thank you
[Music]
foreign
okay keep dying
okay I will
Jesus like how do you come into a chat
room that you've probably never been in
before and you're just like I'm gonna be
annoying
like shut up no one cares
Gotta Have gotta be some type of person
oh Millicent's a bay kidding me
Millicent is up hey
melania's Mommy
[Music]
[ __ ] up my rule
[Music]
oh I didn't have a stamina
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
you're a [ __ ] LMAO I gave you a tip you
clearly need
dog
I'm showing chat this
dog
dog
this is you
okay
this is you
[Music]
this is you
you have four subscribers which isn't
wire your cringe it's your Minecraft
video that says this video has 50 000 50
million 567 426 views and it has 85
views
L nerd shut the [ __ ] up
thanks
now someone in the chat's probably gonna
be like
wow
that streamer really exposed that guy
what a dick
how about he called me a [ __ ] and
doesn't understand the rules of the run
in a stream that he hasn't been in for
more than five minutes
how about don't be a [ __ ] and you won't
get called out L nerd loser
you had it coming
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] off
foreign
God damn
[Music]
there it is
okay
oh my God
yeah I probably gave him the attention
he wanted so now it's my fault
[Music]
right
because I'm the streamer
Melania
[Music]
waterfall territory quiet
now
[Music]
ducked
[Music]
nice
[Music]
nice
[Music]
[Music]
no hit first face
[Music]
excuse me
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
no wow
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh my soul just wow
what the [ __ ]
was that
man
not used to the great Shield stop
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
I am Melania all right please I guess I
didn't roll in time
that last attempt dude I
I almost cried after I died like I felt
a tear in my eye like no joke
felt a tear form in my face
[Music]
it's going good potato
we almost got it
[Music]
okay
yeah we basically got hitless and like
what the [ __ ] happened she had zero
health and she was still alive
like her health bar was gone like 100
gone and she just got up and kept going
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
foreign
why am I doing that
you see that I tried to finesse to maybe
get an iframe to dodge and it didn't
work
okay well aggression there was working
super well until I was like oh wait she
can waterfowl and now it's over
one push-up per death damn my chest
gonna be [ __ ] huge
get way pumped out look like Godfrey out
here
[Music]
foreign
in [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was that
what I think she bled
[ __ ]
it worked
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I think I bled her that's why
oh
[Music]
she's blind I believe it
100 confirmed
foreign
answer me why why did I do that
why'd I do that
um according to every YouTube chatter
ever munchie
Rost Potts
Frost pots
stuff
you were testing her
I can't tell you okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no I thought I was out of range
suffering
[Music]
what are you doing up there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
remind me to not jump attack because the
[ __ ] animation is insanely long
why do this to yourself I had paid
incentive to do this challenge
this was our 100 member challenge
still have to do our 250 member
challenge imagine me trying to beat this
[ __ ] drunk
it might not happen
[Music]
thank you Shaquille
[Music]
or I might be better
what's the white powder around the boss
room
crack
250 is a drunk stream yeah and we're at
282.
500 members
we'll try to beat the game with two
enemies like we're literally doubling
every enemy and boss in the game and
trying to do a run that way
be drunk for a month
I think it looks like snow doesn't it
around the sides
[Music]
[Music]
well at least I can have control of my
build with two millennius
[Music]
[Music]
it's content
[Music]
knew it
my sound keep cutting
[Music]
foreign
nope
what's going on
why does this happen there's your no hit
run right there
there's you no hit run
okay
her kick
[ __ ] barely tapped me and staggered
me and it was over
man dude this is so [ __ ] hard this is
so hard it's [ __ ] unbelievable
it's so hard
no that one wasn't tearjerker I
literally almost had her dead on the one
where I where I'm gonna cry where I
cried
felt like the gun was gonna cry cried
I feel like no health
foreign
[Music]
no I'm here Trevor so we're doing it
like this
nope
I mean
I'm level 122. 122 is good
don't ask me to take a breather don't do
it stop doing that don't tell me what to
do don't do it
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
ERS how about you have Snickers
you ever think about that maybe it's not
me maybe it's you
maybe it's you
oh well we got you can see it there 30
health
26 mind 29 endurance 41 right 31 decks
20 intelligence that we're not [ __ ]
using 28 hate health and 21 arcane
really weird build
[Music]
I hate when you do this combo Millennia
it's quite annoying
[Music]
to do on the first day of the New Year
huh
I didn't like I got hit early so I'm
dead
you can always use a frost spot
hey guys did you know that you could
always use a [ __ ] frost pot did you
know that did you guys know you could
use a frost pot against Melania and
it'll stop her waterfowl that we've been
dodging consistently and has nothing to
do with the reason we're dying isn't
that [ __ ] crazy that you can use
Frost pots holy [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
insane
what incredible new information that
we've been given
wow that's great I've only heard that
once ever thank you I appreciate it
God damn just discovered
that's incredible
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I deserve that I'm sorry
we already beat the fire Giant
we've beaten everyone but Melania
radagon and eldenbeast
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
come on Melania
[Music]
I got baited I [ __ ] knew it
I called it out before it even happened
now at this point I think it's funny
that people are still giving like basic
newbass advice
when I'm doing a challenge run a year
into the game's life cycle
foreign
she was about to do waterfowl and I
knocked her out of it I think
[Music]
he might still do it
he's baiting me again right I think I
knocked her out of it I saw her jump
animation right before I bluttered
not gonna do it I believe
yep
[Music]
or I'm getting debated
[Music]
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
dang it guys I don't feel I don't know
because we just use Bloodhound the whole
way through
I don't know at this point I can't like
I think I'm just getting unlucky these
these on chin
ramp thank you for the two have you
tried these nuts in your mouth
I think we go Raw Dog full time
I'm calling the weapon raw dog now
[Music]
Oh you mean like I have been Brayden
I mean like I just did and died
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now
why does my sound keep doing that
[Music]
I did a jump attack yell at me
[Music]
[Music]
you hoe
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I thought she'd get [ __ ] staggered by
it man
who wants to be consumed
I'm paralling dude I [ __ ] rolled I
rolled I did I [ __ ] did the roll and
I died anyway
[ __ ]
[Music]
damn it
everybody
I should jump
I should try jumping I should jump
jump jump
I should jump
probably I should jump instead of die
jump jump
we tried Frost pots
does that work
new Frost spots like stop her
is that a thing
[Music]
[Music]
wait are you guys serious
do frog spots stagger her
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
we're gonna go blasty
we're gonna go blasting
[Music]
[ __ ]
Ed
[Music]
died to a wall
nice
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that could have been bad
[Music]
Focus
blade this just piss seeping out of my
butthole bro that's all I have to say
hits
man dude it's so weird when I feel like
I dodge and I feel like I dodged
correctly
and then I still get hit it just takes
me out of the fight completely
and then I get hit by a few other things
right away or something
I got a good feeling about this one okay
maybe this
attacks I don't like
it's not very nice
why do you do this to me
I shouldn't do this but I am
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's not like it mattered anyway
I'm getting baited there's the bait
[Music]
not gonna lie pots are useful are they
really
damn
I didn't know that that's [ __ ] crazy
yeah why does she have to be so sexy
like why did they make this boss so hot
is it because from software's sexist
like that one article said
I've wanted from software is sexist
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I love a girl that can kick my ass
it's meant to be a joke chat meant to be
a joke
fortnite
didn't epic games have to pay like a
billion dollars because they [ __ ] over
a bunch of kids and their mom's credit
cards
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
bleed and a staggered
this has got to be the one
that was some weird movement okay
not a big deal
[Music]
now it's a big deal
we're not even dying to waterfowl now
which is kind of concerning
oh stop guys if you feel an actual urge
to give advice I want you to think
before you press enter and just tell
yourself I shouldn't press enter
and then Type L Jake
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
absolutely annihilated on the bait
didn't get hit anyway get baited
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
got a little cucked by the wall that's
chill
damn girl calm down oh
sometimes she just goes batshit crazy
dude like she just will not stop
swinging her sword around
yeah I played Minecraft
's cool
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
wait I feel like ducked me
makes detailed great lorevids does not
know about freeze pots Big L
alright guys
watch this this is the one
Minecraft with viewers would be fun
that sounds like an awful idea for a
Elden ring Channel
[Music]
double that one up there homily okay
[Music]
ooh she's being so weird right now
[Music]
bleed
oh that's so satisfying
I knew it knew it was close
[Music]
I knew it was close
come on man
she's being so [ __ ] weird chat
[Music]
[Music]
maybe
you just gotta hope she doesn't do it
again man but sometimes she does and
then you die
you got this champ
you died
yeah I played Co-op mod with metal
it's fun
[Music]
foreign
we are currently not winning
no
[Music]
however I feel it coming soon I really
do
no joke
there's a bleed
this will be close nice
foreign
now I do a [ __ ] wall
is this fight too hard for our situation
I'm getting demoralized
[Music]
area
I'm getting
demoralize
I hate fears two month old
no radagon's last actually Rick's last
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
damn
[Music]
together
am I getting Invaders I am yes
dude straight up [ __ ] that attack I'm
sorry [ __ ] that like Zoom
[ __ ] that attack
[Music]
Jordan thank you
I'm trying man I'm doing my best I
appreciate it though
[Music]
[ __ ] tried [ __ ] tried huh [ __ ] tried
foreign
[Music]
God damn
[Music]
it's just so RNG it's just so [ __ ]
RNG based
all right
like she just got out of that like send
all my shadow clone [ __ ] everywhere
[Music]
you know a bunch of [ __ ] other [ __ ]
into the waterfowl man like God damn
when do I attack her face too like when
do I [ __ ] even use
the blade do I just run around until she
does the bloom thing
what do I do
[ __ ] man
[Music]
[Music]
come on please
it's probably close to that too
foreign
yeah I guess I should just pull that out
what the [ __ ] was she doing I guess I
should only pull that out when
she does the bloom otherwise I don't
even see a opportunity to do it it
doesn't even matter
plus it's like yeah I get health back
but I I die in a hit so it doesn't even
matter
[Music]
this is so incredibly hard I hope you
guys know that
[Music]
feel like I'm playing like 99 perfect
almost
still [ __ ] dying man
[Music]
this isn't my first time John
[Music]
I've beaten there a bunch of times
this challenge is just like [ __ ]
insane with her though
I got hit a little bit there
cool
[Music]
foreign
like I said
[Music]
[Music]
and dude
I I man
there's no point in complaining about
Melania it's he is what she is
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
I'm trying to run away and my character
just [ __ ] doesn't do anything like
you guys ever hold down run
and then you go but you hold down the
analog the opposite direction it like
sometimes takes a minute
to uh
for it to like do anything does that
like when you turn and want to run it
just doesn't you just don't run
sometimes
I don't know
what is she doing there
oh my God
it's just flailing around like this this
not what she does
totally out of her consistent movement
and just does whatever
I think it's like this
he ran there I don't know
not at all Constantine
maybe bloodhounds
whatever it's called
blood Bloodhound step
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I ran out of stamina because I was
running
oh my God
dying this many times this makes me
think I'm bad at this fight bro but dude
I have been almost perfect
I can't do it man
this is so [ __ ] insane
with this particular build
it's so [ __ ] hard
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
just out of my swing
she's she's right out of my swing to
stagger
she and she might not even stagger there
I don't know because her Poise doesn't
make sense
man
yeah I know I can't make a mistake I'm
quite literally can't make a mistake
but [ __ ] dude I feel like I haven't 99
of the time and I just can't do it
crazy
[Music]
don't don't do that
cut me a break one time
please
where you don't do the perfect counter
attack
when I like decide to do a bloodhound
step one time
like God damn
look
[Music]
Brent horny
I think Brent's horny
I mean god dude
I mean this is like literally making me
think that
there are certain builds that can't be a
boss
so only boss fight where I think that
man
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for not tucking me over there
okay
that's nice
because she could have just waterfalled
and killed me
I mean how do we beat Moog in like 15
minutes and we've been here for like
three hours bro
they're like the same end game
foreign
uh of course that's the one she goes
across the room
[Music]
lead please like
come on come on dude
[Music]
I might just switch weapons again like I
don't know this is
killing me man it's just killing me
just killing me
there's so many unfair things about this
fight it's just insane
[Music]
[Music]
that [ __ ] was all the way down man [ __ ]
you
blade of Mecca
why do people say Shield when when you
block she still gets Health back like
why do people say that it's so dumb
yeah bran is so down bad
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
please
it's just so unlucky
man
I'm like calling it as it happens too
and there's nothing I can do about it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
4K damage
just do it thank you God
God
[Music]
[Music]
that made me so [ __ ] mad dude
that made me so mad just right there
that is such
um
someone summon
summon someone in chat to help
yeah let me just not do the challenge
let me just not do it how about that and
ruin the entire series that's a great
idea
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that's definitely enough
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
that's insane that she did that
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
please please
it's just it's just too [ __ ] hard
it's it is
like I didn't make a mistake the entire
[ __ ] fight and I'm dead because she
just decides to do an attack
that's such [ __ ]
literally anything else I can wanna run
away from when it's I'm that close to
her
[Music]
oh my God the physic would have done
nothing there Chet it takes too long to
do as well you need her to do the bloom
thing then I can
physic takes longer to put on than the
like uh blast
[Music]
I think I'm [ __ ] no hitting her phase
one
[ __ ] man
foreign
[Music]
nice delay you [ __ ] [ __ ] nice delay
just
let me hold it here and you're done just
because I have a slight [ __ ] delay
that was so apparent too that was so
[ __ ] apparent
I wonder what makes her do that like
what makes her delay
sneak why are you even talking about
waterfowl when I'm consistently not
getting hit by it
like the [ __ ] you talking about
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I don't I don't know how to do better
than how I'm playing right now
[Music]
just died to the camera
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I know I did
literally played perfect I pressed roll
my character just doesn't move
and I'm dead
cool
[Music]
why wouldn't I roll there Chad
when I literally played perfect all the
way up to that point and then I just
don't
okay
I'm gonna call that on input delay
Ed
I mean I knew it was coming soon that
just sucks it was right there whatever
all right
[Music]
[Music]
is
she joked facing the opposite direction
and swung around
awesome
it's really cool that you can do that
another reason I think she's blind
yeah I've seen that too pizza I've never
been able to do it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
blade of
it
okay
he's blind yeah that's my theory that
I've said in a couple videos and you
guys have no idea how many people said
he's not blind
hundreds of comments saying she's not
blind
okay
hundreds bro
why are you saying she's blind there's
nothing that tells us that
[Music]
foreign
I got it guys
yeah she doesn't have eyes they're
rotted over
I claim that she's blind in a video
hundreds of comments saying she's not
blind bro
how can she attack us
if she's blind
I'm just like I I can't you know I you
know sometimes man
[Music]
I don't know maybe I should use blood
ounce finesse in some spots
how did how why did that randomly hit me
that time
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
okay she didn't [ __ ] me over we can be
happy about that
come on do it
it's not cool to wait around come on
just do it
this isn't funny anymore
like haha you're baiting that's so crazy
[Music]
you're so cool
[Music]
please
stop wasting my time like what the
[ __ ] going on
that's a bait 100 it's a bait right
there
at this point [ __ ] it I don't know
[Music]
you there
Melania
hello
[Music]
all right no way she doesn't do it now
right
[Music]
nice
nice
[Music]
[Music]
I think this fight's [ __ ]
I said it
I'm putting it out there to the world
this fight's dumb
and it's not even that fun
[Music]
put it on a B in the tier list
great music Great Character design
really cool looking attacks awesome
stage two
your waterfowl is dumb
you do way too much damage you get way
too much health back you have no
consistency with this fight at all
there's nothing that tells you what
she's gonna do besides her doing it
it's a bee
there's some good things some bad things
some good some bad I think she's a
[ __ ] B
her fit whack
her armor whack
her hair whack
let's go drips
[Music]
the most valuable option is using a
broken strategy like rivers and it's
just broken too much in regen right
yeah let me pull one of those out
he's got the Stinger
yeah
what is this [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
that she doesn't want to do it
[Music]
it's like bleed triggers are to not do
it or something it's weird see
[Music]
that's been pretty consistent through
all our attempts right
if she bleeds at any point it's like she
just doesn't do it
weird
nice delay you [ __ ] [ __ ]
foreign
[Music]
that would have been my bad
I thought I was out of range but I guess
I wasn't
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
blade of Mickler I don't know
I is my character not mid-roll there and
it's just hitting me
was that a spatial thing
I don't know
like some Hits come out of [ __ ]
nowhere
I'm mid I I saw my character roll man
I'm now it's not even loading I saw my
character mid-roll and it it just hits
me
maybe like the angle
did that or something I don't know
it won't even load the area now
it's trying
probably gonna crash
hello video game it's not it hasn't
crashed
try crack heighten your reflexes I I
feel like I reacted to that perfectly
I'm mid Dodge and it still hit me
I don't know what to do about that even
if I'm on crack and did it correctly I
still get hit so
I I don't know
game
all right I guess it wants me to have a
breather
what's going on
that's not a way I want to close the
game
all right I'll go get a water and uh
we'll keep going
but I'll go grab a water and take a
small break I do not like taking breaks
from boss fights I don't like it at all
but I'll do it
won't even close
yes
what the [ __ ]
not playing rocket League okay
I'll be right back
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
I'm just typing the alphabet these are
just little letters
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what are y'all doing
I just got back too what are y'all doing
stop it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you guys were giving advice
[Music]
by typing letters
hmm
I think you were just trying to confuse
me
let's start the drinking stream earlier
dude whenever I finish this I'm taking a
couple days off making a normal video
and then we'll do the drunk stream
finishing this run today
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is she not gonna do it
nope I was wrong
toss that theory Out The Window Guys
yeah Sal it all live streams stay on the
live tab now yeah
[Music]
oh Pizza
I would like it to be potato yeah
I think
these streams have been really fun and
they should be its own video like edited
down to where I'm not fighting Melania
for six hours
foreign
[Music]
let me run game [ __ ]
it's so frustrating
die to a wall again
that's why I didn't want to take a break
dude
what is this challenge about yeah it's
probably really hard to know at this
point
because we just haven't been able we
were just trying to beat Melania
I've been doing a roulette I literally
spin a wheel to see what levels go into
my character
we've been doing that the entire run
[Music]
I make my own thumbnails frog
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
this fight makes no [ __ ] sense to the
entire rest of the game
so weird
God damn
oh
some of these like hits just trigger me
to out of my mind
[Music]
[Music]
yeah [ __ ] you
blade
it's the Ronin armor
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
close to this wall
it's so dumb that I have to do this
[Music]
where I'm close enough there
[Music]
what is what what is this
why is she not doing it
like I'm just getting baited
like if there was a reason that she's
not doing it
[Music]
like what the [ __ ]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
man
you wanted my stats
we're trying to do that we're level 122
which is enough for Melania obviously
but we have 30 Vigor and everything like
and then we have a lot of strength
everything else is just like in the
[ __ ] 20s it
it's a horrible build but God damn
I I I've been thinking like the last two
hours like this might be [ __ ]
impossible
it's this is insane
[Music]
[Music]
I I just want to heal
[Music]
[Music]
thank you Jordan
I appreciate another five dollar Super
Chat thank you
I appreciate it
thank you
William are you trying to get banned
because really if you're trying to be
funny you're doing an awful job
clearly not funny
[Music]
so you can either stop or you can get
banned it's not hard
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
like at least tell me if you're trying
to get banned
at least tell me you're trying because
then we can just oh okay you're just
weird
not doing a poll
if he does it one more time he's gone
okay
how are you like this like
how do people do this
whatever
like is that fun to do
I go to xqc's chat or something I don't
know
[Music]
despite the combo
[Music]
she's uh Relentless
right now
[Music]
weirdly aggrove
foreign
[Music]
ferocious accent
yeah it's vodka
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is that like that overhead
is so rare
she like never does this she never does
that
overhead attack why do I hear myself
what the f I hear a vacuum
y'all hear that
hello hello hello oh God okay now it's
gone thank God
I don't know if y'all could hear that
I like [ __ ] around my headset pressed
the wrong button
okay good you didn't need to hear it
your feelings are invalid
yep
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
am I not mid-roll there
what
blade
[Music]
okay
I mean not nothing surprises me with
Melania at this point
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah Stanford oh yeah
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
where is it man
this fight's so dumb it's so dumb
it's like literally broken
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
by the Scarlet rocked
I just like I just didn't stop running I
don't know why
I just kept running
food
I don't know why
I just kept going
made a mistake now I'm dead like wow
foreign
I'm sorry it's like since I restarted my
game she's just doing these like [ __ ]
combos that I've in four hours have just
never seen her do it's just weird
she's being [ __ ] weird I don't know
she's just doing whatever she wants
man dude
you guys know three hours ago we almost
killed her
not crazy
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
she is just this is the worst designed
boss in the game I'm sorry I I just
can't like this is just [ __ ] insane
does she have 50 billion different
variations of every attack
that she can just whip out of her
butthole
[ __ ] man
God
Jesus
give it to me
we killed we killed Moog in 15 minutes
today we killed malekith in like an hour
and a half yesterday
this is just [ __ ] dumb God
this fight officially sucks I don't like
it it's just a bad [ __ ] fight and
anyone that says it's not just has a
build that works for it
if you don't have a specific build
against this [ __ ] it's basically
[ __ ] impossible
[Music]
[ __ ]
like what if some dude who doesn't have
700 hours like I do made some dumbass
build like this because they don't know
what they're doing and they they will
never beat her ever they won't for
months they won't beat her
foreign
Mabel tell me to use a shield again and
I will [ __ ] ban you
got up
how do you like just just
how many people in the chat have to tell
you that a shield does [ __ ] all to her
she heals off hit even if you block it
got up it's not hard just don't say it
in the chat God damn
[ __ ] that was that hard to do
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
G I guess
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
have I done
in the first phase
how many
it's a lot
a lot of times
[Music]
unlucky
mid-swing
how did that hit me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
tell me what to do in that situation
tell me I was just dodging for two
minutes straight
what do I do
what
nothing
you just die
what a poorly designed [ __ ] boss
[Music]
right right Mabel because a shield would
save me there it really would wouldn't
it
with 26 health or whatever the [ __ ] we
have you dumb [ __ ]
God shut up
[Music]
like learn when to shut your [ __ ]
mouth
it's a really good skill for you to
learn
[Music]
[Music]
literally annihilating her first phase
of this queen
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
nice
my God damn
[Music]
Scarlet rocked
what
so I hit her staggered and she just does
it
instant undercut
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and the back of her sword bonked me in
the back of the head and died
no there are so many people out there
that defend melania's boss design and I
just have to believe they have a build
that where they killed her in like five
tries or less
I have to believe that nobody in the
right [ __ ] mind thinks this is a good
boss fight or like a poor like a good
design gameplay boss fight it makes no
sense for the rest of the [ __ ] game
so ridiculously
beyond the Beyond to beat her
like would you guys say Moog is on the
same in-game as her right
maybe a little bit before I'd say
they're on the same like they're
supposed to be two optional in-game
bosses you go there in the concentrated
snow fields
so so like maybe I don't know she is so
beyond the Beyond
unless you have like this crazy
perfectly built build against her like
rivers of blood or some [ __ ] that gives
you a lot of distance
if you don't have that you are [ __ ]
now I'm just talking dying
it's just bad design man just is
like if we're killing Moog in 15 minutes
it should not take us this long to beat
her because guess what we're gonna work
on either at some point I feel it we're
clearly killing it and we're just gonna
the RNG factor of where we kill her and
it won't even feel good when we do
it's just dumb at this point
[Music]
what's stopping you from using rivers of
blood
the entire like the challenge that we're
doing
the whole point is that we shouldn't
have to go use rivers of blood to kill
her I mean [ __ ] man
[Music]
I mean yes we could but based on the
challenge we could go get rivers of
blood and upgrade it to plus 10. we
could do that I don't want to I
shouldn't have to
[Music]
I should not have to change my entire
build to kill a boss
[Music]
if I do have to do that that's literally
bad [ __ ] design
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
blade of Nicola
and I'm not saying bad design like she
has some of the best lore in the game he
looks incredible her attacks look
amazing the as hard as the Halo tree is
[ __ ] wise it's [ __ ] beautiful
uh
leading up to her is just like you
wonder who she is and you finally find
her down here it's it's [ __ ] awesome
but the fight is so poorly done I I I
can't not say it it's bad
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yes Kirby yeah and and just like the
just like the point I made a little bit
ago
imagine some new player out there made
my build because guess what a lot of
people make the mistake
of of a bad build the first time they
play let's say this is their first
character and they get all the
Maybelline all the way to Millennia
looking like this and they were having a
ton of fun through the rest of the game
playing with this build which we were
malikath was pretty hard but we did it
it was doable it felt doable the entire
time and then this that player comes
here
do you think that player is gonna be
like me
[ __ ] no if they weren't live streaming
or like trying to prove a point some
type of point of let's do this [ __ ]
challenge they would go Respec and
completely change the character that
they related to the entire game
that's bad they should not have to do
that
way to just like completely ruin a
player like a player's experience all
the way at the end
and the argument I guess is it's
optional yes it is
I get I guess so I don't see that as a
good argument to the whole point
[Music]
does that make sense
[Music]
I mean you know what it's not optional
it's in the [ __ ] game
that's a bad argument now that I think
about it it's in the game it's not
optional
I didn't see the walls yeah
yeah it's not optional
it's in the game that means I have to do
it
that's how it is
yeah I'm I'm my brain is over here and I
need to be here
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nice bait Nick
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I am Melania
blade of Nicola
[Music]
hmm
I'm literally gonna go full Focus mode
and stop talking until I get it guys I'm
I'm just gonna have to I have to be so
perfectly focused or I'm not going to be
able to do it I'm sorry
when I'm in there I'm not going to look
at chat at all so
yeah when I do it
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
why is she doing that now
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
I mean I don't I don't think she [ __ ]
stops the entire fight there she
literally never stopped attacking
I thought I'd have a window and she'd
just go right into the next thing
I will die on this hill I like the
challenge
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
blade
I mean I've beat Melania like 10 plus
times too every single time I think
she's [ __ ]
just like RNG
when I beat her every time
just like isn't as [ __ ] stupid that
attempt
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
I'm gonna need that one explained to me
I'm just gonna need that explained to me
that made no sense
none
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
that attack has made her stagger when
she does that every time
and it just didn't okay
wow
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
I guess I didn't have stamina or
something I don't know
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
just [ __ ] it's just [ __ ] luck it's
just a luck
can I have some of that can I have some
luck
where she just doesn't totally [ __ ] me
over every single time
I'm like God damn
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
for sure
I'm lucky
[Music]
oh I'm damn [ __ ] dude chill
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
okay
[Music]
out
it's just not fair it's not I'm sorry
it's just not fair
it's just not fair she just did that
even if she had waterfowl I could have
lived there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dude I'm level like 120.
why are you telling me to level up it's
not gonna make a difference
like I'm just annihilating your bro like
but I mean
it's not just like if I make a mistake
then I die like that's a part of it
it's
it's actively trying to [ __ ] me over
every single bite
it's non-stop it's like designed to just
be [ __ ]
like it somehow make me feel better if I
knew the fight was designed to be
[ __ ]
tension
foreign
[Music]
no literally of course not
that would ruin the entire challenge
[Music]
[Music]
oh come on dude
I'll take it
[Music]
[Music]
hi anemia
[Music]
H's remedy
together
[Music]
thanks ax I appreciate that thank you
man
I'm dead inside
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
maybe not I don't know
[Music]
I can't think of a reason why she just
didn't do it there he just didn't water
nothing
just didn't do it
I don't get it
never did for no reason
it's the most inconsistent poorly
designed boss in [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
good
spacing
[Music]
[Music]
another moral boost and reminder for
check not to be giving gameplay advice
Alex
thank you Alex
thank you
I think I'm Hollow I think it happened
like I'm there it happened I'm Hollow
now
[Music]
well I guess I can't go Hollow unless I
[Music]
get
[Music]
man every time oh okay
you whip your body around
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
show that clip all over the internet
to anyone who says this boss is fair
and well designed
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I'm I'm I'm [ __ ] behind her I'm
behind her and it's still
hit me
what do you mean
what the [ __ ]
like how does this keep happening
it's where I'm getting completely
screwed over
like I don't mind dying if I make a
mistake but I feel like I'm [ __ ] not
dude like God damn
[ __ ] how many times does this have to
happen
like I die I [ __ ] dodged that attack
he did and it and it still [ __ ]
killed me God damn it dude
[Music]
did they buff her
I'm dead serious
[Music]
[Music]
let's go
thank you Jordan
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Scarlet Scarlet dropped
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
what why did her
Bloom go after me that time for the
first time in all of our attempts
how
how
it always just goes over
and that time it just didn't
like I can't I can't begin to think how
many examples we have of this
total [ __ ] with this boss it's it's
incredible
it's blowing my mind at this point
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I'm gonna go shura like insecuro
let's turn into shura
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh give me a break [ __ ] God damn oh my
God
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
now you'll do it right no
okay
there you go
[Music]
[Music]
I can't even imagine how many attempts
we've had it's dozens dozens and dozens
can't put one up now
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
why does this happen whatever
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
there were a couple times I wish I had
that so [ __ ]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
I got the input delay thing God damn it
like or not the input delay but I'm
running this way try to go quick back
that way it doesn't work sometimes
that was my fault
it's this I think I slide is that what
it is like my character actually slides
and
you have to go through the animation of
the slide until you can go back the
other way it's really [ __ ] stupid
[Music]
hold on
foreign
[Music]
damn it
Zayna God damn what the [ __ ]
a 50 Super Chat oh my God
thank you holy crap or it's a sticker
it's a cheerleader I appreciate that
thank you
thank you I was deep in that sorry oh I
appreciate that a lot get some W's for
Zaid I think he already did y'all thank
you
oh I am I am dead I've been dead inside
for a while
I mean
what else is there to do but go again
man
I did it again
do it for Ronnie
right
didn't she start this whole mess
[Music]
oh that's good potato
[Music]
oh no
oh no
my character keeps sliding around right
now I don't know why that randomly
started happening but there we are
Zeta thank you again by the way that's
really
nice of you I'm sorry I can't get this
done
I feel bad at this point it's been so
[ __ ] long I thought I saw someone at
chat said dude I went to work and got
back and you're still doing
God damn
I feel like I'm playing so well
I think it's the the thing that's
killing me here
like now I'm not because like I'm
recessing but I feel like I'm playing so
[ __ ] good and I it just won't happen
I mean man
oh
yeah I've been live nine hours
a lot of it's been here for sure
what time is it August 6 30 what the
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I don't feel like I deserve that
[Music]
[Music]
definitely didn't deserve that
[Music]
y'all have no idea how hard I'm gonna
annihilate radagon
and eldenbeast
it's gonna be crazy
[Music]
this approval point
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
can I bleed her second phase just a
question
I don't
I don't think I've done that
[Music]
yeah
back to focus
foreign
man dude getting a little unlucky with
these
getting a little unlucky with these
waterfowls like she's just bonking them
all over the place right now
I'll just have such a better time Jordan
like I'm having like this fight is not
fun it's really not it's just not a fun
fight at all
so over it
it's hard for the sake of being hard
[Music]
wasn't fun at the start
[Music]
what is she [ __ ] doing she just never
does that combo
all right
blade
[Music]
55 420
so whatever
it's a lot of hits
you also can't die on bleeds so that
kind of sucks
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
he literally doesn't die Kirby we've
done it like half a dozen times today he
doesn't
[Music]
not on bleeds either dead blows and
fleas
[Music]
we've seen it so many times today it's
definitely a fact
[Music]
[Music]
you guys think Melanie is getting
annoyed that I keep coming back to fight
her
foreign
like whoa almost you almost got me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
that was weird
come on
come on not like this
it's so boring
and baiter out
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
so unfair dude how many times has she
staggered off those dude how many
[ __ ] times has she staggered when I
hit her with that on the fourth one is
it's been like two three four times I've
seen her do that and just nothing
nothing that time for no [ __ ] reason
she's in the same animation as she's
always been in
God
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
blade
[Music]
so dumb
a lot Phillip
too many
[Music]
what just let me roll [ __ ] game
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ever bro
it won't die
the [ __ ] man what the [ __ ]
[Music]
what do you mean
I didn't do crit you [ __ ]
I credit her she had no health I waited
and then hit her again she had no health
that should be immediate second [ __ ]
face
broken [ __ ]
[Music]
foreign
how hard is that to patch out man
also like but that that doesn't even
make sense Kirby I credit her she went
to no health and then I waited for her
to come out of the Stagger and I hit her
with a normal attack to zero damage how
does that not mean she's [ __ ] phase
two
doesn't even make sense with the glitch
[Music]
ES
what frames she's out of an animation
[Music]
thank you Trump I appreciate that man
trying my ass off here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
like just [ __ ] stop
please
just give like is there no good RNG or
her probably not I guess not
even though I'm playing her 99.5 percent
perfect
on every good run and I still can't
[ __ ] beat her I don't know what more
you want for me as a player
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
why what is that
I mean yeah no [ __ ] that's the entire
challenge but we've beaten every other
boss like not wouldn't take that long
like malachath took a long time but like
holy [ __ ] dude
damn
I don't want to change my build and I
shouldn't have to
I'm playing basically perfect I should
get it at some point
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
I don't think I had stamina I'm not sure
why I didn't go one more back
I just don't I don't know why my
character didn't roll I must have not
had stamina I'm pressing the [ __ ]
button
I've done this enough times where I
shouldn't even think in my and I'll
press the roll button
yeah serious and then people will tell
you like well if you have Frost pots
it's not a big deal
foreign
spots aren't a part of my build
well you should get some Frost spots
[Music]
add them into the build
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
build use it how about I'm playing a
role playing action game and I don't
want my [ __ ] character to use it how
is that hard underfucking stand for
people holy [ __ ]
[Music]
God [ __ ] damn
[Music]
blade
people will defend this boss to the ends
of the Earth even though she's broken as
[ __ ]
how about if you wanted me to use Frost
pots against Melania put him in the boss
room just like you put reichardt's sword
in there it's the same thing it's not a
part of the fight I'm not using it
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
I hate
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
I'm running straight back and I just
there it is I just get hit
why did what did she just get a little
bit further distance there that time
why
have you said I haven't figured her out
completely here Daniel
foreign
and I'd love to know how you figured her
out completely
[Music]
with a rivers of blood
[Music]
maybe maybe a rivers of blood in there
maybe uh maybe some Frost pots maybe
higher vigor
foreign
something along these lines
that you know figure out the Boss by
having the perfect build to do so
maybe a mimic tear thrown in there
what if I don't have those things for my
character or any other person who's
playing this game with the character
that they built through the entire
[ __ ] thing
foreign
[Music]
unlucky
[Music]
no way okay
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
no [ __ ] why am I not moving
I'm dead
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I did the slide again man it was just to
the left
no
I just I don't
I just don't think this is possible with
this build I just don't think it's
possible guys
I really don't I don't think it's
[ __ ] possible with this build oh
[ __ ] man I just have to get so lucky I
just have to get lucky it's it's
and I'm just not getting lucky
I'm gonna cry I'm on the verge of tears
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
why does she get staggered there
sometimes but not every time
[Music]
of course
why did it happen that time and not the
other times
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
man
I did
I [ __ ] rule
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
I know I
did by the way I threw my water bottle
not my controller
I know I did
I hit the [ __ ] button
and it just hits you
why is this fight doing this
[Music]
I mean [ __ ]
this is ridiculous at this point
[Music]
[Music]
blade of Nicola
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
the wrong way I don't know
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
that backhand bro is insane
[ __ ] backhand got me twice now
holy [ __ ] dude I'm sorry Chad I'm at a
point where I'm saying sorry like this
is this is so like I'm embarrassed at
this point I'm literally embarrassed
like how is this not happening
like I feel like I'm just [ __ ] trash
or something
man
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
no what the [ __ ] man
waste all that [ __ ] oh my god dude
no just
cut me cut me a [ __ ] break
please
this is it it's just like did they
perfectly
make it so that she knows exactly how to
counter you every [ __ ] time
like all I did there was maybe space
slightly bad
and she just does the perfect attack to
counter that
[Music]
do the thing
[Music]
I thought I might get lucky
games reading your inputs oh yeah I
forgot that was a thing damn
well then they perfectly designed it
like it's it's flawless
[Music]
oh Alex I got burnt out four hours ago
but I'm still here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yikes
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
what
blade
I destroyed my water bottle
I flung it really hard into the ground
when I had her at like no Health almost
challenge requires to fight Melania I
hope I have a better [ __ ] build to do
so next time
is it Electro
hopefully I said that right thank you
for becoming a tarnished I appreciate
that
thank you very much welcome w
[Music]
that backhand Man I'm The Skin [ __ ]
slapped at this point
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I did it I did the thing again for like
the tenth time wow so cold
[Music]
I want a little bit of [ __ ] on some
of these hitboxes man
I popped that because I'm I feel
confident enough to okay
blade
okay
okay
I mean
that's just unlucky
that's it it's just that am I just
really unlucky is that what it is
I just feel like such a awful player
[Music]
oh
no no
blade of Nicola
like this this makes me feel like I'm
just so bad at the game bro
how I don't know how to ascend to the
next level to do this
I don't know what other level there is
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
really bugs are out of waterfall
or it makes her do it instantly
[Music]
so it doesn't really help us to know
I literally have to keep running away
[Music]
like
[Music]
unfair
and she can just pull it out of her ass
whenever
unlucky RNG I guess I don't really know
what the [ __ ] is wrong with her
[Music]
is this really gonna be a stage one no
waterfowl at all
well of course I bled you so that means
I can't go to stage two where you could
just pull a waterfowl out of your
[ __ ] butthole right now and kill me
there it was
I even [ __ ] called it but I rushed
her this boss is pure [ __ ] my God
I can't find more examples
I can't
oh too far
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
pain
[Music]
what
no no no
no
no she didn't finish that animation
either
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bloom again
God
[Music]
who else thought she was blooming
who else thought
because I did
I thought she was blooming as soon as I
called it
it wasn't a balloon
even he'd even like the animation [ __ ]
looked like she was
like it's so similar
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
oh my God are you kidding me
[Music]
foreign
foreign
you hear the whole game like sound go up
and everything I feel like I'm hitting
inputs and the game like turns off I I
think that's what just [ __ ] happened
like I don't know if you guys can hear
that or not but the audio literally cuts
out the screen freezes for half a second
and my input just doesn't read and then
I get [ __ ] hit
thank you
okay
he's sick I'm dead
huh
explain any of that
she canceled two attacks
that are full animations and just did
whatever she wanted
he fluttered around and just
[Music]
or am I tripping y'all see that it
looked like it to me
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
backhand I always fall for it whatever
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I don't know where the wall is
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
my brother
I'm sorry
I finally meant my match
I'm crying oh man wow
Chicago
good stuff thanks X appreciate the 10
man thank you
oh man
my boy this has been hell for you yes it
has that rock and boss fight who's boss
she is she's a [ __ ]
thank you
Chicago
at a boy
thanks Trey oh man
yeah they're tears of joy for sure oh
man let's go
thanks selecco appreciate that too thank
you everybody yeah
oh my God
we are screaming
thanks
oh man
you see my hand
I'm trying to hold it still
look at that
[ __ ] dude
yeah
hello all right let's go beat the game
[Laughter]
Jake woo thank you man welcome good to
have you oh my god chat
wow
oh yeah we're doing spinny spins
remember that
remember the spins
when's the last time oh I still have
this [ __ ] kids thing pulled up okay
oh man
oh
I [ __ ] this all up to cry now yeah
right out of my seat congrats showed
that dropped and dollar carrot dollar
hash percent hash who's boss
right
thank you potato
oh we [ __ ] did it guys
I'm like kind of a little bit in shock
that it happened I literally thought it
wasn't going to or I was going to be
here for 24 hours I I'm not kidding in
my head at one point I said I am not
going to stop until I get it or I pass
out
I I would have been here till tomorrow
I'm not kidding I would have done that
because dude
there were lots of moments where I was
like this is the first
day of the year right
and I didn't want to give up on the
first day of the year like catch me on
February 7th or something and I would
have been like all right we'll come back
tomorrow but not today man today was
like dude it's the first day of the year
you're really gonna give up
first day hell no
I said that so many times in my head I'm
like I have to do this
five levels five spinny spins two
oh my God what an awful boss
what an awful boss
man Dex makes a lot of sense for that
one okay
spin number two
nah you won't give me that right nah no
shot
nah
[ __ ] bigger what's that
you won't give it to me nah
no way
that's some lame [ __ ] having bigger
up up up oh we're gonna go three for
mine oh my gosh
wow okay let's just hit it again
let's go for mind maybe a fourth time oh
no we're gonna give you Arcane this
[ __ ] didn't give a [ __ ] we wanted
damn it dude well that wasn't worth it
that wasn't worth it gonna go ahead and
run an ad for that one
I found out I can run ads on here so I'm
gonna probably start doing that as
little as possible you literally didn't
get an ad for [ __ ] seven hours so
there you go oh my God
well all right here we go unless you
remember do members not see ads is that
a thing like it is on Twitch
let's go beat up radagon chat let's go
beat him up I want to go beat him up
I want to farm his soul
oh you see them man that sucks on Twitch
if you uh
[Music]
if you're a sub
then you don't see ads
thanks Brent seven seven seven seven
seven at least we get to see this
beautiful cutscene
no ads baby or unless you have premium
then you don't see ads obviously yeah
I knew you headed to new Jake 77
trillion
77777. thank you Brent
I agree spring but
you know YouTube's still figuring [ __ ]
out to be honest
all right well I don't play that many
ads I'm gonna see I want to see the
difference
um playing ads versus not playing ads if
I don't see a major difference then I
just won't play any I think it's
probably smart especially on a 10 hour
stream to like probably run some right
I don't know
I would imagine YouTube doesn't like it
when you don't have ads on a 10 hour
video that'd be like weird it'd be like
hey what the hell man
all right let's fight an actual good
boss here guys
let's find a let's fight a good boss
please don't kick my ass sir
foreign
damn yeah we still die really quick by
the way we still die
really quick
no no I'm not talking about the Eldon
Beast is a good fight I'm talking about
radagon radagon's a good fight
eldenbeast is not a good fight
not gonna
not good
probably one of the worst
radagon is bussin
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is it good against him
isn't he like oh no that's holy I always
think faith is Holy
for some reason
yeah yeah we'll try
oh game's gonna crash
game's gonna crash
super oh do not do this
thank you has no Health yeah our last
three spins landed on mind and not Vigor
they're right next to each other too
isn't that great
no don't crash no
oh please don't do this
yeah I can't handle anything that isn't
Melania
I'm just like beating out waterfowls on
the Eldon bees
oh chat we also have to spin for our
ending I just I remembered we were gonna
do that
okay do I have to just Bonk us out of
here I don't know what to do
yep
damn
damn son
where'd you find that
can you imagine what crashed her in
Melania it did
twice
good night Stan
thanks for hanging out man
I'm tired too but I gotta get this done
today because I am not streaming for
I'm Pro you know it's gonna be a couple
days Chad I'll tell you that right now
I'll probably take one day off
to edit this entire challenge into a
video how does that sound
at least I can cut out eight hours of
today's stream to the last one
and I can just put a prompt Jake fought
Millennia for eight hours watch him go
[ __ ] crazy and then I show little
clips of me yelling at you guys
uh and then
um finally beating her where I cry a
little bit yep that'll be good
that'll be good
I did it Benny I did it
dude I have a zit forming on my lip and
I hate
it anyone else do that
[Music]
anyone else like have a like just hate
the feeling of it's not there yet but
it's forming and I would love it
anywhere else but on my [ __ ] lip
right here
anywhere but my lip
so feels so weird
son
Phil
no chill radagon
oh I didn't use blasphemous
thank you
I lost someone
foreign
week weak to this
that's a lot of damage that's a lot of
damage
that's a lot of damage
it's a hard knock life now I'll get
[ __ ] demonetized unfortunately I have
to most of the time most of the time I
should say if you use video game music
you won't get demonetized
most of the time
sometimes uh not so much
kind of solid strategy for flask economy
okay okay
all right I'll ask you Bloodhounds Fang
against eldenbeast or Blasphemous blade
what should I use
I feel like I can stagger with
with Fang
all right
really blast damn all right
yep time for the worst boss in the game
with one of the best soundtracks
first time I saw this I was blown away
[Music]
I was like it's a universal [ __ ] look at
that thing
it's a penis
it's the greater Will's dick
isn't that amazing
it's quite the start
that's not good I needed that
okay
I feel like I should use Bloodhounds
Fang chat
not finding a huge opportunity here
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I can't see
[Music]
foreign
Stars can you imagine
that video that would have been cool
can you [ __ ] off
apparently not
foreign
what
what
I don't remember that attack
huh
I don't remember that one
that was weird that whole
sequence of events was just like not
normal I don't know
what's [ __ ] normal in Eldon rings in
game nothing
is that just like a was I too close to
that one
I think like if I were further away
would it just not hit me
I just feel so much better that I'd be
Millennia bro
foreign
for that
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
no hit radagon
that was pretty good
oh
thank you
no I haven't had run arcs for eight
hours
really
[Music]
man I wish I could ride on touring right
now that would be really cool
he's got a stagger at some point here
right
maybe not I don't know
[Music]
really
am I just getting really unlucky right
now
what what what's what's what's what's
what's what's what's what's
[Music]
where is my stagger man I know I've
staggered him way before that
on that many hits dude
I know I have what the [ __ ]
also he just spammed every [ __ ]
attack he has dude let me say the f word
one more time dude
oh my God
he threw everything dude
you know what I think we're learning
about well we already knew this didn't
we Elden Ring's in-game
is uh
pretty weird not gonna lie
oh
yeah
no
okay whatever
ow
bomb
check can I just do the normal ending so
we can [ __ ] end this thing like we've
all seen the damn endings can I just do
that
like what it what if we land on Ronnie
and I gotta do all the other [ __ ] to get
her [ __ ] ending or whatever
Eldon BEAST's Channel
turning into a machine gun
not gotta be the proof ending I have
that ending so I'm cool with that
[Music]
wow wow
wow
what a [ __ ] start he went all out
there my guy wow
wow
I've been live for ten and a half hours
that's kind of crazy
just call me xqc dude it's streaming
long hours out here
well no I'm not doing gold mask no
we can go get flame of frenzy really
quick I wouldn't mind that
you might live
foreign
that's quite a monkey
okay
he delayed
a man delayed it
my man delayed his [ __ ] attack
and it [ __ ] killed me bro
I'd love to see the lanes between burn
the nothing can I just burn down the
Haley tree like is that an option for me
like can I can I keep everything else
in the game normal and just burn down
the Halo tree is that that an option
gonna do that
man bro
he can go for forever
why are these hitting me
get in front
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
good I want Nicola to see his entire
life's work burnt to a crisp and see his
rotting burnt sister
in the fire
that's uh how I feel after today
[Music]
too far too much
get pizza for everybody if you're
getting pizza
foreign
foreign
okay be a good giant Universal peony
that's not not doing that
you're being annoying
I call him the Elven peepee
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I'm a little mad about that one
he only I've never seen him like do that
like that
I don't even know what's going on
foreign
okay
I don't know I guess the eldenbeast is
just randomly unstaggerable now as I'm
doing giant jumping jump attacks
with a bloodhound's Fang plus 10. he
should definitely be staggering and he's
just not
I hate that move where it goes I hate it
too because it is obnoxiously too close
to you when you're running away from it
why
[ __ ]
maybe I should try Bloodhounds finesse
yeah
yeah I didn't get hit last night
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
you don't
and I want to finesse out into the fire
here though
that's good
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
why did they make Elden Stars last
so long like who thought of that
who thought of that man
they last entirely too long
way too long
ah
Chad I haven't eaten all day I'm [ __ ]
hungry
foreign
okay
laughs
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah I agree corvick
Oh I thought he glitched out damn
kind of wish he did
foreign
hits in a row there
[Music]
[Music]
really
okay
sure
that one made a lot of sense
oh man
[Music]
let me run away now
[Music]
foreign
I've died with three times
what the heck dude that attack I don't
think I've ever seen that attack before
today
ever
what is happening do I just have the
worst luck on the [ __ ] planet when it
comes to Elden ring dude God damn
man
[Music]
okay how do I how do I dodge that attack
and if it's just don't be that close
when it happens I'm gonna scream
foreign
I guess
it's the bigger check ability don't tell
me that don't tell me that dog don't
tell me that that ain't true
that is not true
uh
yep
man dude can I just get this done please
use Frost spots
right
foreign
just want to be done dude
oh I can't backstab you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
agreed
can you blow down finesse through the
laser the bloodhound's Finesse does not
have as many iframes as it seems like it
should
huh
okay
I'm really growing not very happy right
now
about that attack in particular
thank you doctor
appreciate that
thank you
I'm just gonna pop it I don't know
what's gonna happen something dumb's
gonna happen I can tell
yeah he piss waved at me again I don't
know what's going on
yeah it's my build cursed or something
police don't randomly hit me what the
[ __ ]
okay this fire reaches way further than
you guys would ever think
why do those hit me when I'm running
directly to the side like it'll just
randomly [ __ ] hit you it's so dumb
nope that's that attack
okay there we go he pissed waved me
again
sick man
oh [ __ ]
we like that
[Music]
a [ __ ] course
what
excuse me
what
what's going on I am I getting trolled
by the devs somehow
this is not normal
it's not
it's not
like is this game that against Bad
builds
really that hardcore against Bad builds
[ __ ]
maybe that's the title of the video chat
Kelvin ring doesn't want you to have a
bad build
that's kind of what I've learned through
this entire challenge to be honest
anyone else
it's what I've learned
what
I totally dodged that
okay
okay
[Music]
I've seen people I've honestly have seen
a few people complain the in-game can
ruin a specific build I I think so I
think this one is just like
I think we're good enough to get through
it but like [ __ ] man is it it's
completely unforgiving
there I mean there's so much that it's
like
[Music]
there's so much to where it's there's
nothing I can do does that make sense
like the last few times with the Eldon
Beast I don't think I can do anything
about what happened like what he decided
to do in that moment
besides maybe if I had more help
that was my bad
oh yeah imagine you had holy a holy
build
end game would be insane
it'd be insane
I just want to be done
we're quickly coming up on my second
longest stream ever
I did one 24-hour stream on Twitch and
I'll I said I'd never do it again
hungry and I want to take a shower
because I bet I smell really bad
is there really a kid in my chat like
telling me what to use
but can you not read
no I never want to do this challenge
again here's the thing though
technically if you do this challenge
yourself
it could be uh
it could be really good
like it's it's RNG based on what happens
so
technically this could go very well
[Music]
no I'm just playing the game drunk
drunk the next that's the next stream
we're gonna do is gonna be I'll plan out
the drunk stream and do it then
you know my hair is going crazy
oh so you're not gonna do it yourself
you say
I just want to watch me do it
foreign
[Music]
the game inputted for me what the [ __ ]
I did not press that button
holy [ __ ] that threw me for a loop
maybe I no
okay well [ __ ] man
I don't know why I don't think I pressed
it
look my controller's kind of [ __ ]
with me
and then my character didn't roll again
I don't know the controller feels fine
I don't know
what else
damn bro kill
oh no chill no chill yep
yep
I feel like this Samurai kid is might be
brain dead
you literally might be brain dead
I bet you let I bet you ask a lot of
questions in high school don't you
like you annoy the [ __ ] out of your
teachers because you just like are
incapable of understanding something on
your own
[Music]
oh he has input detection it isn't your
fault
actually coded your inputs and react
accordingly oh man damn bro
L nerd
foreign
oh wait never mind it's not I didn't see
the other message
I thought it was beautiful
imagine
there we go yeah
[Music]
he's going crazy boys
there's not been a window to hit him for
a while isn't that fun
oh man
oh man
dude that might be you bull I'm gonna
ban him anyway he's clearly just a
[ __ ] idiot bye-bye
bye bye
that might have been you will
yep
what what do all enemies in this game do
when they have low Health chat
we've learned so much about Elder ring
this playthrough we really have
we have learned a ton about this game
thank you
foreign
Jesus Christ
that's a great speed run isn't it holy
[ __ ]
youble of the golden order
when he falls below 30 he regrets
leaving Ronaldo and takes it out on the
player
that's a good one I like that
foreign
foreign
[Music]
well time to become the olden ring oh
[ __ ]
[Music]
man
I forgot he can grab [ __ ] like that and
he really went into the next
attack very fast didn't he
did that not feel like a kind of a
ridiculously fast grab
does he have a fast grab actually
usually he has to load it for a really
long time right
and then he'll then he'll grab you that
one was instantaneous
my bad
Ronaldo went crazy because Ronnie died
and wanted to use the egg to rebirth
Ronnie
um I said that in a video a really long
time ago
I I think it could be a combination of
like her heart being broken and Ronnie
dying
[Music]
um
gosh that's a good question I wonder if
ranala knows Ronnie's alive
in spirit
honestly she's insane so she might not
know anything
thought rebirthing herself was to make
herself perfect that's one of the
theories that she's trying to make
herself perfect to be good enough for
radagon
and she's you know making a bunch of
herself
over and over again that is one of the
theories on it yeah
yeah I think she might be too far gone
to know
[Music]
I think if I had to guess
I'm gonna do it for the channel potato I
will
see how it does I'm nervous of how the
how the video will do but I will try
thank you
I can fix her
[ __ ] okay
foreign
that could not have gone better
I think radon figured it out and put
Ronnie's two fingers in the in space
I think that's why they're blue because
they were low on air so they turned blue
uh and then they crash landed in the
hole where we find Ronnie at the end of
request line
I don't know
the extent of rodan's knowledge of the
plan but I think he knew something
foreign
just give me really good RNG please
this is the best RNG you've ever seen
it's not the worst
that's not whoa okay
I thought he was doing uh
I wish I could hit you
oh of course I can
wow you're all the way over there now
that's crazy
that's so crazy
this fight sucks so bad
like give me torrent right here and I'm
happy
[Music]
and I can jump those or something I
don't know
okay that was kind of cool
remember what I said about RNG
not going well
in that department
run
I mean
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
I really
give him second man
this is insane
[Music]
oh my God
please
I almost died because he went over my
[ __ ] head right there
foreign
[Music]
okay rings are chill
[Music]
foreign
why did drips get deleted
yeah he said Frost spots
oh we did it chat we [ __ ] did it oh
my God I can't believe we did it all
remembrances ruin Roulette Challenge
complete
we [ __ ] did it dude I am in shock
right now that we were able to do that
holy toledo
wow dude
we actually did it
should we do spinny spins for the [ __ ]
of it
let's see what we get
oh wait
hold everybody hold hold
yeah
uh hold
we actually did it dude
I started stream at 9 30 this morning it
is now 8 45 and we have done it
Ben thank you for the five dollar uh
super sticker I believe thank you very
much
thank you
we have five spinny spins that's fun oh
walk of turtles with a 20 Super Chat
I hate that I exist in this world
knowing what rule 34 is and that Rani
has four hands in all seriousness
congrats on overcoming Millennium and
the Elden schlong rock on gesture
um
all right
thank you
Turtles for the 20 Super Chat that's a w
get some W's in the chat uh for
for that thank you
[Laughter]
what's rule 34 never mind never mind
never mind all right let's let's do some
spins
[Laughter]
five spinny spins let's go
oh of course not on Vigor I mean imagine
if we got bigger it not that it matters
anymore
uh but of course we didn't do it what
are the odds we get bigger now oh we did
it happen well just had to [ __ ] and
moan about it and there it is we got it
not that it matters anymore
my God
oh it's porn okay I figured
okay yeah okay you know it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter
keep it spinning keep it spinning let's
just get this [ __ ] over with
all right uh probably ins nope it's Dex
I think
and last spinny spin until we pick the
ending
and
strength
endurance okay
ladies and gentlemen
this is the build that a roon roulette
would make
here he is in all his glory Bloodhounds
Fang plus 10 which is honestly our
choice
um Blasphemous played plus 10 which was
our choice as well
ronan's armor
gigaface
31 vigor
30 mind
30 endurance
41 strength
33 decks
20 intelligence 28 faith and 23 arcane
would you recommend the build
let's pick the ending
excuse you guys are right
we have one more boss to beat don't we
we're not done yet
we do have one more boss to beat
you're right
how could I forget
I'm so sorry
okay
we have to be the god of the greater
will
the god of Gods
if Melania was five hours this will be
10. Rue
all right guys get ready for a 24-hour
stream we're going up against Rick
hopefully we get lucky and he only gives
us a clone of point zero zero zero one
percent of his true power
maybe we'll get somewhat Lucky in that
regard because we have not gotten lucky
in basically anything else
let's see what we get
can he hurt us
we did not fight him
we did not fight him at any point
Have We Become Rick
himself
it's the only explanation
no I I know I didn't find him Angel we
said right at the beginning not to do it
I ran by and never came back I know I
didn't fight him
definitely
whoa
I must be him
it's me
I need to take my posts right here
and wait for the next tarnished
I wonder when he does leave like in with
you know Jokes Aside
I wonder
when did I fight there's no way I fought
him someone said it right at the
beginning of the first stream
day one said save Rick for last and I
said oh yeah sure
and then I didn't go in here
I got the stream playing on the second
tab dude I gotta see this
I gotta see this now
I gotta see it myself 15 minutes in day
one
no shot bro
am I thinking of the mage build
is that what I'm thinking of
15 minutes you said
we're in there
yep
oh no
it won't play
I want to see
yep we did
pain bro
well
damn
gotta redo the entire run yeah I was
thinking of the mage build you're right
dang
yeah another tutorials pop up will they
pop up now at this point after we beat
the [ __ ] Eldon base that's insane
all right we'll go to the first stream
damn I wonder why we did that huh
I could have swore
okay
it's time
to change our spinny spin for the first
time in the Run guys
we have
blame
a frenzy ending
which we can do
we have
uh
fracture ending
we have
uh what's fias called
duskborne
um those are the three we have that we
can do is that okay if I just spin these
three
[Laughter]
I'm not gonna do gold mask
I'm not gonna do it I could go finish
Ronnie's I guess
if it lands on Ronnie I'll do it
I swear to [ __ ] God if it lands on
Ronnie I'm going to be upset okay I'm
going to be upset about it
now knowing our luck through this entire
[ __ ] ordeal it will so I'm expecting
it to
here we go
these are these are the these are the
big ones so we're gonna do this
let's see what we get
[Applause]
foreign
foreign
how do I open this again
what do I do I went all the way up here
do I have to go back
just remove it it's not that deep
it is that deep
at this point this entire experience has
been a joke we did Kill astel as Seal's
dead
as [ __ ]
super dead
he's like super death at this point
family
together
here's some more money please go grab a
snack RQ I will as soon as I finish
guys we got the black knife
we did that
we did all that and why can't we do this
thank you doctor
[Music]
it's teleporter we already went through
that whole area dog
we already did that
that's not how you do this
it's just a part of it
we already did it
we already got the black knife we
already went through the study hall we
already got
a thing of the top of Ronnie's Tower
I mean [ __ ] man
God damn it
I guess I have to kill the doll huh
that's sick I'm looking forward to that
uh
uh I can just run backwards right
hopefully it's bugged
you have to cleanse your sins
why did it land on that
never mind
I'll get you your simp ending roulette
[ __ ] wheel
I will get you your simp ass ending
well [ __ ] is it actually bugged
do I have to talk to Minnie Ronnie like
I actually have to physically talk to
her
for this to work
I don't just have to have it in my hand
you [ __ ] kidding me
[Music]
don't
man
I have to go to that specific Grace are
you kidding me
yeah wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow oh
a dogged fellow aren't we [ __ ] you or is
it merely thy Habit to talk to dolls I
talked to your mom's doll [ __ ] I hadn't
expected any soul to recognize but now
the cat I'm the Elden Lord eliminate
baleful Shadow name why why do I need to
do this no I don't no I don't care
I don't care dog all right that's sick
can I go down here now and not do this
that'd be lit yo
that'd be so lit yo
oh I know I'm loved I'm a [ __ ] cool
person
I like myself I'm a cool cat
did I expect to play Eldon ring today
for 12 hours I did not
ask me if I care Oh Shadow I think it's
a good start to the year to be honest
tell the two fingers fingers I can't
think of a better start to my ear
to heal ow
stop it ow
stop it
foreign
now I can finally stand before them
farewell my dear
she didn't say tell easy and blight I
love them like she usually does wait
who's she talking to is she talking
about is she talking about Stan before
her two fingers
probably
let's not overthink that one that's
probably it
AO where do I go now I think my brain's
dead
I think I died okay here we go
yeah it's got to be the two fingers
she usually says tell EG and blood I
love them
you didn't say it that time
you guys know I ignored two girls today
to do this stream for you
isn't that crazy
I wonder why I'm single
probably because of this huh
yeah
do I have to fight this dragon
yeah I do
they didn't like video games
no one of the girls
is Katie
he asked me what I was doing today at 9
30 in the morning and I never answered
her because I was streaming
guess what she does she's been playing
Pokemon
on her switch
so she does like games a lot
if you even tried Ellen ring but she
said she wants help and I'm here doing
this
I want you all to know that
you can run past the Dragon
I'm gonna go ahead and run past the
Dragon
I'm gonna go ahead and ignore the dragon
if that's okay with y'all
my brain dead I'm gonna sleep so good
though
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
you sound a little tired
yeah I'm gonna go get married yay
instead of talking to girls today I'm
gonna go get married do a [ __ ] Blue
doll
let's go
through gamer
through gamer life out here
let's turn on that Lantern you guys
wanted me to [ __ ] get
uh oh
that's not good
I'm even gonna watch it I'm that
dedicated
why would you want to talk to real girls
Melania and Ronnie are better
through
that's true Melania pegged my ass for
eight hours today like what how what
could I ask I couldn't ask for more
I got pegged for eight hours
dislike having a girlfriend right
all right guys
hand gets old though
switch hands
duh
no girl would have railed you like
Melania did today
that is straight up facts so it was the
my Lord
cause I needn't have warned thee I am
pleased however
to a fitting choice I really am the best
to the night sky
[Music]
travel the path of the Lord and once all
is done
we shall see each other once more
nice
I propose she said yes chat
she said yes do we have enough in to use
that a [ __ ] course we don't wow
that's cool okay
let's go
let's go
he turned Hollow I'm the Elden Lord
[ __ ]
I'm about to marry a doll
let's go
heck yeah bruh let's go
I'm way down in my seat by the way
I'm not this short
um
sounds like he needs a vacation I'm
going to Mexico in March so I'll look
forward to that
the battle is over I see
that'll be fun
that'll be my vacation
until then I go hard on Elden ring I go
hard in the paint
I'll marry this blue doll as many times
as it takes to get 500 000 Subs
oh by the way I ordered my 100K plaque
and it's coming
it's on the way
they said like two weeks though so
that's kind of lame
but that's pretty cool
[Music]
bring Bud spray I mean it's at a resort
so I'm I think we'll be good
I do solemnly swear
hmm
every living being and every living Soul
when is reichardt here
now come at the age of the Stars
GG Jake hope to see another week
yeah definitely gonna do this run again
guys here making it's a chill night
thanks
I appreciate it this idea was protators
idea guys can you believe that
isn't that great
doubt
and loneliness
thanks potato
stretch
Ed I do appreciate that though thank you
um
I'm sorry
it's not your fault it's the wheel's
fault
my God this game is hard with a bad
build
my fair consort eternal
guys I bagged a MILF he's like thousands
of years old Isn't that cool
[Music]
death looking forward to the drunk
stream but take a long rest after this
jerky oh yeah
guys I will not be here tomorrow okay
I might be back the next day if I get
the video done okay
[Music]
but I won't be here tomorrow
okay
drunk stream is next because we hit 250
members I appreciate that
and Finn thank you for the five I
appreciate you thank you thank you
our next goal is 500 where we'll double
every boss in the game and try and beat
it like that
double every enemy in the game by the
way not just every boss every enemy in
the game will be doubled if we hit the
500 members that'd be cool
we'll definitely try that hopefully with
a better [ __ ] build than that piece
of [ __ ] we use today
um all right
I'm gonna go eat and go to bed
that's my plan and shower because I
smell I can tell
all right guys I love you you do
I'm gonna leave though
and uh I hope you all have had a fun
time here on your first day of 2023 I
know I did
um
actually pretty fun I wouldn't do it if
it wasn't like fonder with it so thank
you guys you make it worth it
happy 2023 what a great way to start the
year of just being a [ __ ] Legend at
Elden ring as we are
um look out for a video on this entire
run I hope it does well or I'm gonna cry
okay bye guys I love you and I will see
you in probably a couple days maybe uh
maybe you know soon okay have a good one
okay bye guys